COMMITTEE SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL
COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING SAID HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE. COVERING
GUIDELINES IMPLIES WITH THOSE
ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING. HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WHAT'S WTH ALL OUR
MEMBERS TODAY PARTICIPATING-
TODAY SOME MEMBERS OF THE- CARE
ACT WITNESSES WILL BE TESTIFYING
REMOTELY THE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FIGURE. WHO
ARE PURCHASE PREMIUM OR REMOTELY
FOR THOSE SOME REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID ELIMINATE. ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I S. IT TIME
YOU WISH TO RECORD THAT YOU TO
REACH YOUR HAND FUTURE OF. IN
THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO I NEED PLEASE
SELECT FROM YOU BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING ARE I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU ARE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU.
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME. AND THEN YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TO THE
EXTENT. OF IT WILL ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'RE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC INTO THE HEARING ROOM
TO EXTEND SOCIAL DISTANCE.
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND IT WILL
BE N. M. WILL ALSO BE USING THE
TELECONFERENCE RETURN THREE
OFFICIALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. PROCESS
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANSWER NOW. IS
TO. THE. 877-291-6364 THE X. SIX
CODE IS THREE FIVE THREE ONE.
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE A DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS CLEAR
FIRST. P. PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. CAN OR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL. ONE AND THEN ZERO PRESS IS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR THE OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU.
A LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATE TO
CALL YOU'LL HAVE. MY NUMBER AT
THE TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE YOU
WILL NOW ADDRESS. YOU'LL BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US. TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK ON THE
TELECONFERENCE OR CHRIS. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING. ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE-
TELEPHONE IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR.
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I'M MAINTAIN THE-
DURING THE HERE. TEST IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
FROM THE REMOTE. MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR- CONNECTION MUTED.
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE HEARD
AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS. HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED LAST WEEK. FOR
ANYONE PHYSICALLY PRESENT HERE
TODAY PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASK ON
COVERING YOUR NOSE AND YOUR
MOUTH AT ALL TIMES SO. I SEE
THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM- AND IN
THE ROOM SO MISS ROY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CALL.
SENATOR ONE CASKEY HERE ALI HERE
REQUIRE STERN. OKAY OF A QUORUM
IS ESTABLISHED- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE WILL FOR ALL. YEAH
FROM ISSUES ON- VOTE ONLY WE
WILL CONTINUE THOSE MATTERS TO-
NEXT WEEK. FEBRUARY NINTH FOR A
VOTE THAT MEANS SEE CERTAIN
ISSUES NUMBER ONE THROUGH TWENTY
FOUR THAT WE KNOW VOTES THAT
WILL TAKE TODAY BUT WILL
CONTINUE ALL THESE CALENDAR
MATTERS TO ATTEND- NEXT
WEDNESDAY AT NINE O'CLOCK
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST FIRST SO
LET'S GO TO- ISSUES UP FOR
DISCUSSION I HAVE THE AIRPORT-
THE ENERGY COMMISSION- THE FOR.
CAL FIRE- CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION AND- WE HOP ON BOARD
WE'RE DOING ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE. THE GOVERNOR'S CAP AND
TRADE EXPENDITURE PROGRAM IS
DISTINGUISHED FROM THE SENATE-
PHILLIPS. LET'S START OFF- I
BELIEVE WE HAVE THE AIRPORT WILL
START OFF WE HAVE A EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SEGAL AND- THE DEPUTY
FLETCHER AND DEPUTY CHIANG.
ACTUALLY IT GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS SIR DO I GO WITH THE
FROM THE FINANCE ALL KICK IT OFF
AND THEN I'LL LOOK BACK ON MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE AIRPORT WE GET
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT MORE. AND
PLAN- HELLO I'M GOING TO PROVIDE
A- OR- OF TWENTY GOING TO GOVERN
BUDGET CAP AND TRADE.
BACKBENCHER HIGHLIGHT IN THE REV
YET. ALTHOUGH ARE PROPOSED A
FRENCH FRAMEWORK. I IN REVENUE
BUT IT'S GOING TO COVER BUDGET
AT- TWENTY TWO THREE OCTOBER
WOULD BE THAT ABOUT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS AND IT DOESN'T
THAT ALL CURRENT AND ADVANCED BY
WITH THE- BELL AT THE LOWER
PRICE. NOW SIMILAR TO ENSURE
PRACTICES. METHODOLOGIES BECAUSE
THE ADMINISTRATION IS. NOT
SPECULATING ON CHANGES OR PRIOR
TO NOT OFFEND ANY FORM OF MARKET
SIGNAL WHICH HELPS MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY OF THE OUTER. HOWEVER
WE DO UP THERE REVENUE ESTIMATE.
TO REFLECT ACTUAL THAT THE
OPTION OCCUR SO WE WILL BE A
BRIEF ARE READY YET OR THE MAYOR
VISION YOU REFLECT ANY UP AT
THAT POINT. NOW IN HER OF THE
EXPENSE- THIS MONTH IMAGERY CAN
BE REALLY BE FOR CAP AND TRADE
BETTER THAT PLAN. WHICH WAS
DEVELOPED THROUGH UP EXPENSIVE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS ANY DO YOU
RECOMMEND. TO HELP TO. HIS
PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. PLAN. B. ARE BOTH GOING TO BUDGET
WRITER FLAT- THEN THAT HELP
MAINTAIN COURT GRANT BUT BY
PRIME ALL RIGHT BY MICHAEL. TO
HELP ADVANCE EQUITY AND ALTHOUGH
THE AGNO. BE MORE ARE YOUR IN
INCLUDED IN THAT TWENTY ONE BY.
WHICH CAN TO SUPPORT KEY CLIMATE
SPORTS YEARS. I WE- IN ADDITION
TO THE CONTINUE A CORPORATE-
SOME OF THE KEY IMPACT IN COVERS
BY PROPOSAL. IS SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE MILLION A YEAR AT
AT OUR OF A STICK POINT ONE
BUILDING DOLLAR PACKAGE. TO
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE THEIR
MISSION VEHICLES. WITH A FOCUS
ON. NOW THIS TARGET US ACTOR
THAT IS. FOR THAT HAVE OF THE
QUITE- ANOTHER OF HUNDRED AND
FORTY GOING INTO OR BECOME AFTER
. FOR WHICH OPERATES THE MEASURE
- IN COMMUNITY WITH
DISPROPORTIONATE. TO POLLUTION
NO TARGETED EHRMANN AT MEDIUM TO
PROGRAM. AND THEN ALSO THERE'S A
ADDITIONAL THIRTY DOLLAR YOU
DEPLOY IT LOCAL AND REAL TIME
POLLUTION MONITORING INCLUDING
CLAM AIR AND TALK THE
COMMISSION. ENDED HAVE ASKED ME
TO CALL IT. CALLED NOW
BACKGROUND MY COLLEAGUE THAT HE
EVER BORDER GOOD FURTHER
ELABORATE OUT THE DETAILS.
BEFORE WE LEAVE YOU. MISTER
AGUILAR- YOU'VE READ THE L. A.
O.'S REPORTS ON WHAT THE
EXPECTED- MODERATE VIEWS ARE
GOING TO BE I MEAN THE ACTIVITY
THAT WE SAW IN NOVEMBER. WITH
THE- EQUITY- HOLDERS COMPETING
IN THE MARKET I MEAN IT'S NICE
TO TALK ABOUT THE HISTORIC. LAWS
SAPHIR APPROACH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE BUT ANY CASUAL OBSERVER
WHAT WENT ON THE MARKET HAS TO
BE PAY SOME ATTENTION TO THE
OUTSIDE PLAYERS THEY'RE NOT
PARTICIPATING OUR EQUITY MARKET
I MEAN OR CAP AND TRADE. THEY'RE
DOING IT IN EUROPE. WHY THE
INSISTENCE ON. THE LITTLE THE
AMOUNT OF FOR SINCE WE HAD TO BE
DOLLAR IN THE- THAT YOU HAPPEN
TO COMPARE WITH THE WITH THEM
AND THIS. YOU KNOW. THE PROCESS
YOU YOU. YOU CALL ABOUT OF. SIX
SIGNAL SEVEN MAY. IT SEEMS IT
SEEMS WERE ON A DIFFERENT DAY
THAT THAT BOAT HAS SAILED THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SIT THERE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE FACT IT EQUITY PLAYERS ARE
LOOKING AT THE FEBRUARY MARKET
LOOKING AT THE FEBRUARY AUCTION
AND- WE KNOW FROM NOVEMBER THE
FUTURES ALLOWANCES FOR THIRTY
FOUR DOLLARS. YEAH HOW DO I KNOW
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
MAINTAINS. A CONSERVATIVE
APPROACH AND NOT WANTING TO
SPEND ANY MARKET. FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION YEAH DURING. THE
GROUND YOU HAVE MET A COW OR-
WHAT HAS BEEN OCCURRING. AT THE
WEEPING BAD DOES PROVIDE A
GREATER LEVEL OF INTEGRITY AND
THE OXEN AUTHORED BY NOT HAVING.
THE STATE HANDLES MARKET SIGNALS
HOWEVER WHAT I WILL KNOW IS. ONE
OF THE DOCTORS DO OCCUR AND THE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES ARE
AVAILABLE BEEN DOES BECOME
AVAILABLE. BURKE IN ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN AND BE REQUIRED BY
THE NECK BAFFLE. IN THIS-
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- WE'RE
ASSUMING- A LITTLE OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FROM
ADDITIONAL REVENUES. FROM THE B.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OPTION. AS
A RESULT OF THAT THE LAST-
ACTUAL. AND THAT HAVE NOW BEEN
INCORPORATED INTO THE EXPENSE
REQUIRED FOR THIS FOLLOWING
YEAR. AND CLOSE THOSE REVENUES
ONE THING WITH YOUR LIFE. THEN
THEY WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
PROPOSAL SO. IT REALLY JUST
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF A OF I
KIND OF BLACKED DURING EXPECT A
ONE DOLLAR AVAILABLE BUT- BILL
DOLLARS WILL BE AVAILABLE IF
THEY DO MATERIALIZE AT HIGHER.
UPRIGHT. WELL THE SYSTEM
PROGRAMMING AG I KNOW YOU KNOW%
THE TO IS MY YEARS BEING THE BY
CHAIR. AND WE HAVE A RICHEST.
HERE IN THE SENATE OF NOT HAVING
MANY OF OUR PRO FUNDED MANY OF
OUR PROGRAMS MANY OF OUR
PRIORITIES FUNDED. AS WITNESSED
BY THE EXPENDITURE PLAN THAT YOU
HAVE NONE NONE OF THE SENATE
PRIORITIES THAT WERE CALCULATED
LAST YEAR AND MANY OF THEM. THAT
DID NOT GET FUNDED OR GOT TO GOT
FUNDED FOR ONE YEAR HAVE NOT
BEEN INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
DISCRETIONARY. BUDGET SO I'LL
JUST LEAVE IT THERE BECAUSE WE
GOT THE AIRPORT COMING IN AND-
THAT WE HAVE. SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT WELL THE PROGRAMS MAY
ADVANCE EQUITY WE REALLY LIKE TO
FOCUS AND LEAST THAT THE ON DUTY
REDUCE CARBON WITH THE THEY
KNOCKED REDUCE CARBON ARE THEY
AYE CRITERIA POLLUTANTS-
POLLUTION PROGRAM. OR THEY
CHOOSE SOMETHING ELSE LIKE THE-
SAFE DRINKING WATER PROGRAM
THAT'S NOT REALLY A CARBON
PROGRAM BUT LET'S HEAR FROM THE
AIRPORT I THINK WE HAVE A-
EXECUTIVE. TO SIEGEL. YES GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND THINKING THE
STRAGGLERS THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY%
TO SPEAK TODAY I'M CRITICAL
SINGLE AND GET THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER ARE AND I'M JOINED BY
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICERS CHECK
BUT SURE ANY CHANGE I WILL COVER
CARBS BCPS THAT ARE PROPOSED TO
BE FUNDED WITH STRANGER AFRICAN
A QUITE A FEW OF THESE SUTTER
SPECTER TIME GET YOUR QUESTIONS
ON THE RIGHT AND EACH WITH
MINIMAL INTRODUCTION AND
TRANSITION. AND COVER THEM IN
ABOUT A MINUTE OR SO EACH THE
FIRST OF THESE BCPS ZERO MISSION
VEHICLE PACKAGE NOW BUILDING ON
YOUR LEADERSHIP WITH THE BUDGET
LAST YEAR THIS YEAR'S ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE OR IS AS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS TO
TRANSFORM THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR CUT CARBON CUT CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS AND PRIORITIZE AN
EQUITABLE TRANSITION AND SHARING
THAT THESE INVESTMENTS SUPPORT
ACCESS TO CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
BEYOND VEHICLE OWNERSHIP THIS
PROPOSAL PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES
FOR COMMUNITY BASED MOBILITY TO
LAPTOP PRIORITY POPULATIONS IN
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES EXPAND
TRANSPORTATION CHOICES LIKE
BICYCLING WALKING AND TRANSIT
OKAY AFTER. YOU CAN GET IN THE
PUBLIC ACROSS. THE COMMUNITIES
WITH ALL STAKE. TO THE AN
INTERNET PROBE THAT ARE FUN.
INDEED WE ALREADY MADE GREAT. IN
FUNDING A PER. BY THE TWENTY TWO
ONE BY. WITH OVERTWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ALREADY OUT. TO
EXISTING PROJECTS MOST OF THE
REMAINING FUNDING ANTICIPATED TO
BE FULLY ALLOCATED BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR SO THERE'S GREAT
DEMAND FOR THIS WORK. AND EVEN
OVER THE OF THE PACKAGE. ALSO
INCLUDE. AND IT SORRY. I ALWAYS
GET WAS GONNA SAY GO THROUGH. I
KNOW THAT WE HAD CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL LAST YEAR'S PACKAGE INCLUDED
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THIS CURRENT YEAR
THIS UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE TEN AND-
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR SO WE
HAD THREE YEARS HUNDRED AND- OR
FORTY MILLION EACH YEAR FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION. AND THEN
ONLY ONE YOUR FIRST CV R. P.
WHICH IS AS AS WE NOTED IN OUR
ANALYSIS THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
IS A VERY POPULAR PROGRAM BUT SO
IS TO C. B. R. P. YET THERE IS
NO MONEY FOR A SECOND YEAR. OF
THE CVR PETE- BEFORE AS AN
AUGMENTATION SO I'M I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND THE THEME THAT YOU
WANT TO CONTINUE WITH THESE
PROGRAMS INVESTMENT. BUT THEN
YOU HAVE ONE GLARING. OMISSION
OF ANY MONEY RATHER THAN THE
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY TWO AND-
SEVENTY SIX WE WANT FOR CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL I GUESS OF NEEDED
CLARIFICATION WHY WOULD YOU PUT
MORE MONEY IN A MULTI YEAR
PROGRAM THAT YOU ALREADY HAVE
THAT HASN'T BEEN. THE MONEY
HASN'T BEEN EXHAUSTED. YES WELL
I SPEAK TO THAT SPECIFICALLY
RUNNING THROUGH THE OVERALL
BCPS. SO IN THE CASE OF CTRP
LEICESTER'S ALLOCATION- CAME
WITH DIRECTION TO US TO WORK
THAT ACROSS THREE YEARS
DEPENDING. ON WHICH IS WHAT
WE'VE DONE SO THERE'S ACTUALLY
QUITE SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS
INSECURE P. THE NEXT. NEAREST.
THIS I'M NOT ON. AND SHE THAT
MONEY REACHED ALL POPULAR.
ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME. THANK
CLASS THE EXPENSE OF CAR FOR. TO
THE TUNE OF I BELIEVE ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR SO. WE ACTUALLY
BELIEVES VERY MUCH IN BOTH
PROGRAMS AND- ALTHOUGH THE FIRST
DEPARTMENT FINANCING PARTICULAR
FUNDING CHOICES. ON THERE IS
BUDGET TROUBLES. SO WITH THAT
AND I'M SURE WE'LL COME BACK TO
THAT LET ME JUST RUN THROUGH AN
- THE LARGER. PROPOSAL SO THE
BOYS ALL AS A WHOLE INCLUDES
ABOUT TWO POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITION. TO EXISTING
APPROPRIATIONS TO KERR. NO MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE FUNDING TARGETED
FOR HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENT. EXPAND
INVESTMENTS FOCUSED ON PASSENGER-VEHICLE INCENTIVES FOR LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS. ANALYST DR
MOST DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES THEIR COMMUNITIES
FERTILITY PROJECTS. ULTIMATELY
STRENGTHENING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARTNERSHIP NOW FIND KEY
PRIORITIES IDENTIFIED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTYONE BUDGET ACT.
DELIVERING BOTH EQUITY AND
SCALE. LET ME GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF WHAT'S IN HERE. ON THE FIRST
THEY'RE QUITE SUBSTANTIAL LOW
INCOME ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INCENTIVES TO THE CONVERSATION
YOU'RE JUST HAVING. SUPPOSED
TWENTY FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT SEVENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT SMIDGEN SHAFT
WITH THE READERS THE GENERAL
FUND. TO CONTINUING SUPPORT FOR
LOW INCOME CONSUMER PURCHASES
INCLUDING CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
TRANSNISTRIA PURCHASES FOR LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS AND OTHER
EQUITY PROJECTS. ALL FOCUSED. ON
LOW INCOME VEHICLE OWNERSHIP. AS
ALSO A VERY. INVESTMENT ZERO
MOBILITY FOUR HUNDRED NINETEEN
DOLLARS PROPOSED GENERAL. WHAT
FOR YOU TO SUPPORT SUSTAIN
COMMUTE BASED TRANSFER EQUITY
PROJECTS THAT EXPAND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS. NEARBY
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
INCREASING ACCESS TO ZERO
EMISSION MOBILITY HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. IS
LOCALLY DRIVEN PROJECTS RESPOND
DIRECTLY TO CRITICAL MOBILITY
NEEDS IDENTIFIED BY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
RESIDENTS ON THE FRONT LINES.
OBJECTS ALSO CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT THE ACTIONS INCLUDED
IN THE LOW INCOME BARRIER STUDY
FOR OVER COMPARISON IN
TRANSPORTATION ACCESS AND BUILD
UPON THE VISION ADVANCE TO
CLIMATE ACTION PLAN FOR
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS.
INCLUDE LEGACY PROJECTS LIKELY
MOBILITY OPTIONS THE SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECT
CLEAN MOBILITY IN SCHOOLS AND
PROJECTS THAT FACILITATE
COMMUNITY BASED TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS ASSESSMENTS CASTING
BUILDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT. WITH THIS FOR A
PROPOSAL ANY PUBLIC PROCESS
CARBS ALSO CONSIDERING BUILDING
A PILOT PROGRAM IN CONSULTATIONS
CAL STOP. INCENTIVIZE AND REWARD
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES FOR RE
PRIORITIZING PROJECTS FOCUSED
EXPANDING TRANSPORTATION CHOICES
PROJECTS THAT REDUCE VMT IN LINE
OF THE STATE CLIMATE EQUITY
GOALS INSTEAD OF ROADWAY
EXPANSION PROJECTS THAT
UNDERMINE THE SCHOOLS. ELIGIBLE
PROJECTS INCLUDE TRANSIT ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION BACK FOR MOBILITY
CARSHARING VANPOOLING. BIKES IN
THE BIKE SHARING AND OTHER
INNOVATIVE INVESTMENTS THAT
REDUCE OUR DEPENDENCE ON
DRIVING. THE NEXT CHUNK THE
PROPOSAL ADDRESSES MEDIUM DUTY
HEAVY DUTY AND OFFERING ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES THAT YOU MET.
BY FAR THE LION'S SHARE OF.
ENTER CIRCLES. THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
NEW DOLLARS- IN FROM THE GENERAL
FUND OVER FOUR YEARS TO DEPLOY
ONE THOUSAND DRAYAGE TRUCKS AND
SIXTEEN HUNDRED TRANSIT BUSES
REDUCING HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
POLLUTION ACCELERATING
ELECTRIFICATION FOCUSING ON
SOURCES THAT WAS PARTICULARLY
HIGH EXPOSURE RISKS TO
COMMUNITIES. IT ALSO INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME GINGER OF
SUPPORT ZERO MISSION CLEAN
TRUCKS BUSES OFFERED EQUIPMENT
ACROSS A VERY WIDE RANGE OF
CLASSES INCLUDING CONSTRUCTION
AGRICULTURE FINALLY TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND IT FOR FOUR YEARS TO REALLY
ACCELERATE AND ENABLE
ELECTRIFICATION ALL LEVERAGING
BOTH BATTERIES AND FUEL CELLS
BILL WITHOUT OF COURSE IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION KCC AND OTHER.
PARTNERS FINALLY. THE PACKAGE
ASIDE A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL. FOR EMERGING OPERA.
THIS IS TWENTY IN SORTS OF THEM
. OF PILOT. IN HIGH CARBON
SECTORS WHERE WE CAN REALLY
LEVERAGE ADVANCEMENTS THANK OF
THE MARITIME AVIATION LOCOMOTIVE
OFFERED SECTORS IS INVESTMENTS
WHICH RECORDED CLOSELY CC AND
OTHERS WILL HELP MAINTAIN
CALIFORNIA'S ROLE AS THE HUB OF
THAT MARKET CREATION INNOVATION.
NOT ONLY THE GREAT WORK TRAINING
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES BOOK CELEBRATING
THEIR MISSION SOLUTIONS THE
TAPESTRY SECTIONS TRANSPORTATION
ECONOMY PACKAGE AS A WHOLE IN
SHORT IS INTENDED TO REALLY
ACCELERATE A TRANSITION. ACROSS
ALL OF THESE FRONTS TO WEATHER
BCPS. SECOND OF THESE IS THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO OVERALL
EXPENDITURE PLAN THE FOCUS ON
THE COMMUNITY- PROTECTION
PROGRAMS. AND GRANTS SO. AS YOU
KNOW. NEARLY ONE THIRD OF
CALIFORNIANS AND PREDOMINANTLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN OVER FOUR
HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS. FOUR
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY TO
REPAIR THAT'S A CRISIS SOMEONE
LIVING IN ONE OF THESE COMPANIES
ON BRIDGE BRAINS THERE WAS TWICE
THE AMOUNT OF CANCER CAUSING
DIESEL PARTICULATES. THAT
SOMEONE THAT LIVES IN MORE
AFFLUENT IN OUR COMMUNITY US.
AIR POLLUTION BURDEN LET'S BE
FRANK IS THE RESULT OF A LONG
HISTORY OF RACIAL INJUSTICE
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM POVERTY
DISINVESTMENT. TO ADDRESS THIS
DISPARITY LEGISLATURE LAD
PASSING OF THE GOVERNOR SIGNING
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTEEN
WHICH DIRECT KERR DIRECTING
CARBON YOU CAN JUNCTIONS LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS. TO ACTIVELY
ENGAGE WITH MEMBERS OF HEAVILY
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES FOLLOW
THEIR GUIDANCE THE DRESS LOCAL
CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS AND
TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT SOURCES OF
CONCERN. THERE VARIETY OF
STRATEGIES. THE FIRST OF THOSE
STRATEGIES COMMUNITY- PROTECTION
OR CASH INCENTIVES. THESE FOCUS
ON ADDRESSING DIRECTLY THE
CONCERNS OF COMMUNITIES TO
CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM
DISPROPORTIONATE. BURDENS AND
SPEAKING ABOUT. THE FOR THOSE. I
REALLY REAL ON AS THEY HELP
SECURE A TO INVEST IN THE
REDUCTIONS LOOKING NEED. WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN OVER TO THREE HIGH
THIRTY YOU'RE WITH ALL. STAY
THOSE INCENTIVES TO REDUCE
FIFTEEN THOUSAND TIME. OF NOT
BLUE FORMS. HUNDRED OF REACT
ORGANIC GASES AND SEVEN HUNDRED
TONS OF DEADLY PARTICULATE
MATTER SHOULD B. C. P. REQUEST A
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN INCENTIVES TO CONTINUE THIS
VITAL WORK. THE SECOND ON THE
STRATEGIES MUST BE SLEEPY- AND
ADDRESSES EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEENTHS PARTNERSHIP LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS WHICH DO SO MUCH
OF THE WORK. OF THE PROGRAM. S.
B. C. P. THERE FOR REQUEST FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE FOR AIR
DISTRICT ACCOMMODATION. WHAT
WILL THEY BE DOING ALL THEY
CONVENE COORDINATING AND
SUPPORTING COMMITTEE STEERING
COMMITTEES- WITH A SUPPLICATION
STIPENDS LANGUAGE AT THIS
pIN THE PROCESS. REYES AND VOICES
- MY PLANS MISSION PROGRAMS WILL
TO COMMITTEE STATE A CLAIM.
MONITORING NOT. THE REPAIR FOR-
CRITICAL IN. OF DIRECT. OF
POLLUTION SOURCES. THE
IMPLEMENTED BEST AVAIL RIGHT
CONTROL TECHNOLOGY THREE. THEY
REQUIRE THAT YOU'RE CRACKED OF.
STATIONARY SOURCES LIKE
FACTORIES. AND THEN THE AND WE
WANT TO CONTINUE THAT WORK.
ANOTHER THIRDS FINALLY OUR
COMMUNITY HERE GRANTS. THESE ARE
DIRECT KRASSENSTEIN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA TRIBES THE GRANTS
HELP AWARDEES DEEP IN THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THE B. SIX
SEVENTEEN PROCESS HELPS BRING
THEM TO THE TABLE. AND THE BILL
TO PASADENA ACTIVELY IDENTIFY
EVALUATE AND HELP ME TO REDUCE
AIR POLLUTION EXPOSURE TO
HARMFUL EMISSIONS AND
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITY DRIVEN
WAYS THE B. C. P. REQUEST TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TREATING THESE
ASPECTS. AND WHAT LAST BASICALLY
TO TALK ABOUT THIS IS THE ONE
INVOLVING CENTRALIZED EXPANDING
COMMUNITY- MONITORING. SO YOU'RE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR IN ONE
FINE. TO HIRE CON. CONTRACT HE'S
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY WELL
MONITORING APPROACHES TO
DETERMINE AIR POLLUTION IMPACTS
IN COMMUNITIES STATEWIDE. THE
FOCUS AIR TOXICS. TOXICS OF
COURSE POSE A THREAT TO
COMMUNITIES THIS POLLUTION MAY
NOT BE MEASURED BY THE EXISTING
FIXED MONITORING STATIONS THAT
WE IN THE DISTRICTS CURRENTLY
OPERATE. WELL MONITORING CAN
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE DATA
COVERING MORE COMMUNITIES WHICH
MAY ENABLE FURTHER INSIGHT INTO
REMAIN SOURCES OF AIR TOXICS
NEEDED BETTER UNDERSTANDING THE
STEPS ARE NEEDED TO REDUCE THESE
BURDENS. THIS TO BE A LIMITED
TIME CONTRACT. OR CONTRACTS FOR
TWO YEARS DURING WHICH THE
CONTRACTORS BUT ENGAGE IN
OUTREACH WITH COMMUNITIES TO
MONITOR. IN APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS EFFECTIVE
MONITORING. AND HELP COMMUNITIES
UNDERSTAND INTERPRET THE RESULT
THAT. THAT'LL BE INTEGRATED
CARBS EACH YOU VIEW WHICH IS THE
STATE'S PORTAL. FOR COMMUNITY-
MARC. AS OPPOSED AUGMENT
COMMITTEE- PROTECTION PER AT THE
TOP ABOUT THAT WAS A STAB AB SO
SEVENTEEN. FRANKLIN COMMUNITIES
ALL ACROSS THE- RATHER THAN ONLY
THOSE LACK FOR THIS IN THE SIX
SEVEN. ARE SMALL SAMPLES MUSIC
NEED NOT. AS LONG UNDERSTANDING
OF COMMUNITY. HELPING TO
POTENTIAL. ASSOCIATE FOCUSED
COMMUTING AGENCY ACTION AND HELP
PRIORITIZE LOCATIONS FOR
ESTABLISHMENT OF COMMUNITY STALE
CUSHION MODERATE IN THE FUTURE.
THAT NUMBERS ARE ALL THE- ON IN
TODAY'S HEARING BELIEVES I THINK
YOU YOUR TIME YEAH AYE AND- I'M
- AND OUR FOR. AT AN APPROPRIATE
TIME AGAIN I JUST FINISH
QUESTIONS AS WE HAVE TO WE WANT
TO GET ALL THE AGENCIES IS WIDE
THE CABINETRY PROGRAM. PAY FOR
ALL THE BILLS I MEAN YOU'VE
OUTLINED THE BENEFITS OF AIR
POLLUTION YOU KNOW I WAS THE
CHAIR OF THE QUEUE WHEN WE NEED
TO PASS. SB SIX ONE SEVEN THERE
WAS ZERO FUNDING FOR THAT. IT
WAS A GIANT LEAP THAT WE SAID WE
WANT TO DO THIS AND THERE WAS
ZERO FUNDING WHY ARE YOU NOT
USING SOME OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
MONEY WHY IS IT NOT PART OF THE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL PROGRAM.
WHY IS CAP AND TRADE PAYING FOR
A 100% OF THE CEREMONY THE
PROGRAMS WHEN THIS IS A DESIGN
TO REDUCE CARBON. YOU KNOW
INSURANCE MY APARTMENT A STANCE
COLLEAGUES ON THE HEALTHCARE SHE
QUESTION. I MEAN I'M NOT I'M NOT
I'M NOT A PROBLEM I WON'T
DISPUTE THAT IT WOULD BE A FINE
PROGRAM I'M JUST SAYING YOU'VE
COME HERE WITH THE HUNT PERCENT
BEING FUNDED THROUGH CAP AND
TRADE PROCEEDS. AND ALL THE NEW
PROGRAMS. AND THINGS COMING FROM
THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FUND.
FOR INSTANCE OR PUBLIC HEALTH
FUND. GET WERE URGENT. FROM OF
FINANCE I'LL GIVE KNOW THAT
MYSTERY USED. CAP TRADE PLAN
HOLDEN WE- ARE WE'RE- ARE NOT-
ONLY. A FULL COVERAGE BEVERAGE.
GOT MISSION BROUGHT DELIVERED
OPEN. I INCLUDING PUBLIC L. AT
THE- PARTICULAR AND- BACKING A-
NOW ALL KNOWS. YOU KNOW WITH IN
. BUDGET AND EVEN AND LAST YEAR
BUDGET IS BUDGET. TALKING ABOUT
THE ENTIRE. BUDGET WHICH IS
ABOUT TWENTY TWO. FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. I COMBINED LAST YEAR'S
ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN BILLION.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PROGRAM
DAHLE. FEET A LARGE GENERAL FUND
FUNDING. FOR- THAT THEY DELIVER
SOME OF THE BENEFIT. ARE
PARTICULARLY LOOK AT THE BUDGET
WITH THAT PACKAGE. MOST OF THAT
FACT. ACTUALLY GENERAL FUND IT
WITH A PIECE OF IT COMING FROM
FROM THE CAP AND TRADE- BUT WE
DO. DEFINITELY LOOK AT OTHER
FUNDS AREN'T THAT THAT SUPPORT.
I'M THESE PROGRAMS. NOW I THINK
WHEN HAD TALKING TO. B. EVERY.
DOC AND FIND. YOU KNOW. THEIR
FOR PATROL FUND DOES HEAVILY. ON
ONE THANK OAK THE RED. THAT
RESULT. FROM DEMONSTRATION
COMMITTEE THAT MAINTAINING A-
RESERVE THEIR- AND YOU KNOW THE
ARE. ALWAYS KIND OF A- GOING. TO
DO ON. THOSE OUT THE REFUSE
MATURE. THOUGH THAT THAT DOES
CREATE. SOME PRESSURES ARE.
THEIR I MEAN WHAT HAVE. IS THAT
YOU TO AWAY LETTER. TO TRY TO.
CARBON RICH. PROGRAMS OF ALL THE
MONEY IS TAKEN FOR AIR POLLUTION
I. UNDERSTAND COURTROOM.
POLLUTANTS IS AN IMPORTANT. ROLE
BUT- YOU GOBBLED UP ALL THE
DOUGH. ON A DISCRETIONARY GO.
TOE TO. EXPAND ON THESE AIR
POLLUTION PROGRAMS AND WE'VE
GOT. NATURAL WORKING LAND WEEK
THERE'S NOTHING HERE ON METHANE
REDUCTION. THERE'S NOTHING HERE
BUT NOTHING TOO HUGE. A HUGE
PROBLEM AND WE DON'T CUT IT A
PENNY HERE. YET YOU'RE THESE
FROM. SIX WHERE'S THE BALANCE
WHERE'S THE WHERE'S THE BASKETS
AT LEAST AT LEAST ON YOUR HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE TRUCK YOU ARE
GETTING A HUGE. CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS IMPROVEMENT BUT WE
ARE REDUCING CARBON. SOLVED
LOOKING STIPULATED THAT BUT THE
OTHER WAS A REALLY. ALL THE-
MONITORING AND EXPERT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND ALL THAT I DON'T
SEE THE CARBON DIVIDEND. YEAH SO
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
EARLY POINT DEMONSTRATION LOOK
THAT OUR OUR CLIMATE FUNDING
POLITICALLY. WHICH INCLUDE
MULTIPLE FUNDING FOR NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE TRADITIONALLY- JOB
FINDER FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND THERE'S ACTUALLY
ALREADY FUNDING INCLUDED AND IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET- INTO TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE PROPOSED BUDGET
AND IN SOME CASES IN THE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR BUDGET
ASSOCIATED WITH THE MULTI YEAR
AFTER THAT. FROM LAST YEAR'S
WEATHER TO GRAPPLE MAPPING
PROGRAMS- LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
WE'RE THE METHANE ONE DAY
THERE'S FORTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND
BILL AND TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE I WHICH IS THE- BUT THAT
THE COMING BUDGET THE FARMER
PROGRAM THERE'S A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS BILL AND-
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR
THE POWER PROGRAM- SAME GOES FOR
URBAN GREENING- AND URBAN GREEN
HAS TWO MORE YEARS OF BINDING
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AT
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR- THERE
IS ALREADY FUNDING. FROM THE
GENERAL FUND THAT WE ALLOCATED
IN ACROSS MULTI YEAR PERIOD BUT
MINISTRATION LOOK AT OUR CLIMATE
BUDGET CLIMATE FUNDING
POLITICALLY WHICH INCLUDES
MULTIPLE FUNDING FOR IT THOUGH
EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T THE BILL
PROGRAM UNDER CAP AND TRADE.
THEY ARE FUNDED. FROM THE
GENERAL. VERY GOOD WE ALL. WELL
LET GET ON TO THE NEXT PRESENTER
- IS ALL FROM THE ARAB. OF
CENTERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST HAD A QUICK
FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT
WE'RE DIGGING DEEP ON THE AIR
MONITORING- ISSUES- AND MAYBE
IT'S A- POLICY CLARIFICATION
FROM THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
BUT- CAN IS THE PROPOSAL TO BE
ABLE TO USE THIS AIR QUALITY
MONITORING FUNDING- COULD IT BE
ESSENTIALLY USED FOR- ENTITIES
THAT HAVE COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS
UNDER THE CLEAN AIR ACT OR
UNDER- SB THIRTY TWO SUCH THAT.
WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE OFFSETTING
LEGAL OBLIGATIONS OF ENTITIES TO
DO KIND OF AIR MONITORING
ALREADY IN OTHER WORDS- TO
SUBSIDIZING POLLUTERS COMPLIANCE
ACCOUNTS BECAUSE MY BIG CONCERN
IS WE JUST HADN'T ANNOUNCEMENT
TODAY OF A OF A SETTLEMENT
AROUND AIR MONITORING WHEN IT
COMES TO LISA CANYON- AND IT
TOOK A MASSIVE LAWSUIT FROM THE
COMMUNITY TO ACTUALLY START TO
GET SOME CONTINUOUS AIR
MONITORING IN THE REGION EVEN
THOUGH. WE KNOW IT'S BEEN
LEAKING SINCE IT BLEW OUT IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
SUBSIDIZING WERE PROPOSING TO
SUBSIDIZE THAT KIND OF
COMPLIANCE ACTIVITY FROM AN
ENTITY LIKE THE GAS COMPANY WITH
THIS ACCOUNT- THAT DOES SEEM
LIKE. A SMART USE OF GREENHOUSE
GAS DOLLARS AND IT ALSO SEEMS TO
CONTRAVENE THE UNDERLYING
DIRECTIVE IN THE GOVERNMENT CODE
THAT WE SORT OF LAID OUT HIS
FIRST PRINCIPLES RIGHT THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE THERE SHOULD BE
ADDITIONAL EMISSIONS WERE
ACHIEVING NOT JUST SUBSIDIZING
COMPLIANCE AS YO AS YOU. AS IT
WORK SO THE ANY ANY SENSE
WHETHER THERE'S RESTRICTIONS ON
THIS FUNDING- TO SORT OF NON
COME. ENTITIES OR NON COMPLIANCE
RELATED ISSUES. ANSWERING THIS
IS EATING CHECK ON THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND I CAN TAKE
THAT QUESTION SERVICES THAT
THIRTY MILLION. AT B. C. P. OR
THE MONITORING THE INTENSE AND
THAT THE CITY IS TO CONDUCT
MOBILE MONITORING IN COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE. TO DEVELOP
BASICALLY A SNAPSHOT OF WHAT
YOUR QUALITY LOOKS LIKE AROUND
THE ENTIRE STATE SO IT'S REALLY
AT A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT-
PROGRAMS. WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO. SO IS THAT PROGRAM STILL
PROVIDING FUNDING THAT THE ONE
I'M REFERRING TO. WHEN YOU SAY
THAT PROGRAM IF YOU'RE SAYING
THAT FIXED- FOR IN FOR NON
MOBILE IS THAT IN IS THERE ARE
THERE NON MOBILE ELEMENTS TO
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR AIRMATA
IN THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WE HAVE
ANY EXISTING MONITORING NETWORK
WITH. AND THERE'S A STATIONARY
MONITORS THAT ARE ACROSS THE
STATE AS WELL AS SORT OF SPECIAL
PROJECTS THAT REDUCE A SPECIAL
PROJECT MONITORING LIKE IN THIS
PROGRAM THAT MONITORS IN
COMMUNITIES IN ORLAND GAS
FACILITIES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
BUT THERE IS NOT FUNDING FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT IN THIS
REQUEST BUT THERE IS PASSED
FUNDING FROM PASSED CAP AND
TRADE THAT SORT OF AS AS A- ARE.
THE GENTLEMAN FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SAID THAT SORT OF
ALREADY BUILT. INTO THE SYSTEM
IS THAT'S RIGHT HOW TO LOOK AT
IT. A PAST MANY HAS APPLE TREE
YES SO WE ARE WE ALREADY.
DOLLARS IN YEARS. THAT'S
CURRENTLY SUBSIDIZING THAT
ACTIVITY EVEN IF IT'S NOT IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET ITEM. AND I JUST
WANNA BE CLEAR WHEN YOU SEE THAT
ACTIVITY JEANINE STATIONARY
SOURCE MONITORING BAT- YEAH FOR
LIKE SHIP COMPLIANCE FOR SIT.
FOR ENTITIES THAT ARE AT ALL THE
PRETTY UNDERSTATED TITLE FIVE
OPERATING PERMIT OR SOME OTHER
CLEAN AIR REQUIREMENTS. BOB IS I
KNOW. THERE NOT BEEN. I'M
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FIND
MONEY FOR THOSE KINDS OF
PURPOSES. THERE IS MONITORING
FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW AS- AT
MISTER SIEGEL TALKED ABOUT THERE
IS MOEY THAT HAS GONE FROM
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION PLANS
FOR EXAMPLE OR- EIGHTY SIX ONE
SEVEN PROGRAMS AND SOME OF THE-
THERE IS AN- ELEMENT OF EIGHTY
SIX ON SEVEN OF. COMMUNITY ARE
MONITORING PROGRAMS- BUT THERE
ARE NOT AS FAR AS I CAN REMEMBER
GREENHOUSE GASREDUCTION
PROGRAMS AND IT PAID FOR. I'M
COMPLAINTS ENTITY MARCHING. OKAY
THANK YOU. YEAH LET'S WILL GO TO
A QUESTION FROM SEN MCGUIRE AND
THEN- CENTER DALIAN AND I'M I'LL
JUMP OVER TO THE ALLEY AND LYFT
FORGOT TO. GET THE ALLY OWES
OVER SATAN JUST SO EVERYBODY'S
ON THE SAME PAGE. THIRTY TWO
WHICH THREE. EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR
FROM CAP AND TRADE TO GO TO
MEDICATION EXPIRED AT DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. SO
WE'VE BEEN IN TWELVE MONTHS OF
THE LOOSEN. AB THREE NINE EIGHT
WHERE YOU CAN SPEND IT ON.
PURSES AND EVERYTHING UNDER THE
SUN SO I JUST WANT TO REFRESH
EVERYBODY'S MEMORY THAT WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO SPEND THESE
MONIES UNDER THE OLD AB THIRTY
TO. A REGIME WHICH IS THIS IS
OUR THIRTEENTH MONTH UNDER AB
THREE NINE EIGHT SAN REQUIRE I
DON'T THINK YOU SO MUCH OF
MISTER CHAIR IN A REALLY GOOD
POINT IN THAT AND I WANT TO. GO
BACK TO WHERE THE CHAIR WAS IN A
VERY BRIEF RESEARCHER IN REGARDS
TO THE ISSUE OF METHANE BUT
FIRST AND FOREMOST- LOOK I THINK
BOTTOM LINE IS UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
TAKING A CONSERVATIVE APPROACH
WHEN IT COMES TO CAP AND TRADE
FUNDING. I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE TWO POINT SIX TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION- WHERE THE-
ADMINISTRATION THINKS THAT WE'RE
GONNA LAND WITH THAT FINE.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO ON PAGE
NINETEEN IN REGARDS TO AT THE
BOTTOM. OF THE CENTRALIZING NEXT
MANY MODERN. ONE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIRTY
MILLION- WON'T BE SUFFICIENT TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE A STATE WIDE
APPROACH. FOR THAT COMMUNITY
MONITORING. AND WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING I KNOW WE MAY NOT
GET IT HERE TODAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOLLOW UP. OF HOW THEY
INTEND TO BE ABLE TO ROLL THIS
OUT IN MORE RURAL PARTS OF THE
STATE NUMBER ONE. THE OTHER.
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO TAKE. IN ON
BOTH OF THE AT ONCE. IS A-
SERGIO FROM DEPARTMENT FINANCING
HE SO MUCH SIR FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. I UNDERSTAND THAT
METHANE REDUCTION ESPECIALLY.
CAN'T MINORE MANAGEMENT. HAS
BEEN IN NINE CAP AND TRADE FUNDS
BUT THAT'S JUST BE REALLY
CANDID.THE ONLY WAY THAT WE'RE
GONNA HIT THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE COMMITMENT A 40%
REDUCTION. BY TWENTY THIRTY IS
THAT DAIRIES ARE EITHER CLOSING.
OR THEY'RE LEAVING THE STATE.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GONNA
HIT THAT AND WE'VE UNDERFUNDED
CONSISTENTLY- WHEN IT COMES TO
MANURE MANAGEMENT IN BOTH LARGE
AND SMALL GEHRY SITES WE
CONTINUE TO DO THAT IN THIS
BUDGET AS WELL. SO I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE'RE GONNA COME BACK AND
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT A
COMMITMENT THAT WAS MADE AT TO
THIS INDUSTRY UNDER THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE AND HOW WE CAN HELP
THEM AHIEVE AT 40% REDUCTION
WITHOUT THEM EITHER. BUT THE
CALLES INTO U. HAUL. ARE CLOSING
THEIR DOORS. TO HAVE A COMMENT
FROM FINANCE. I DON'T TOLERATE
YOU'RE JUST KIND OF THE- LOOK
FORWARD TO ONGOING DISCUSSION
THEN AND AGAIN AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE THERE WILL BE ANOTHER BIG
IT REVENUE AT THE END OF YOUR
VISION THE REFLECT KIND OF ANY
ADDITIONAL OXFORD BROOKES B.
FROM FROM THE ACTUAL THAT OCCUR
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS SO-
YOU KNOW I DO. DIGITAL
DISCUSSION. BUT AND- THIS IS A
FRIENDLY THIS BEEN A PER OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THREE FOUR
YEARS ON ON- METHANE AND-
CHESTER'S MANURE MANAGEMENT
CENTER DOLLY. WELL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I HAVE A ITS
KIND ALONG THE LINES OF THE U.
S. SENATOR FROM THE SECOND
DISTRICT JUST MENTIONED SO. YOU
KNOW. THE QUESTION I WANT TO ASK
IS IF YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED IN
CALIFORNIA THAT. THE COST OF
LIVING IS SKYROCKETING. WE HAVE
FUEL PRICES THAT ARE FOUR
DOLLARS A GALLON YOU IT'S A HALF
A MILLION DOLLARS TO BUILD AN
APARTMENT. WE HAVE SINCE WE PAY
60% HIGHER ELECTRICITY RATES
THAN AVERAGE IN THE NATION. AND
A LOT OF THAT IS DIRECTED BACK
TO THE POLICIES THAT COME OUT OF
THIS CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD
. AND QUITE FRANKLY THAT START
RIGHT HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE HE
AND THEN OUR- YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION THEN FIX OUR
PRIORITIES BUT I BUT BUT MY
QUESTION IS. AND THIS MY
QUESTION ACROSS ALL THE ITEMS
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY IS HOW DO YOU. COME
UP WITH. THE REDUCTION IN CARBON
WHO ACTUALLY MEASURES WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET FOR WHAT WE'RE
PAYING FOR. YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
VERY LOUD ABOUT. CARBON IN THE
STATE I WANT TO LEAD IN ACTUALLY
REDUCING CARBON AND I DON'T
THINK THE PRIORITIES OF THESE
BUDGETS ACTUALLY IT THAT WE'RE
WE'RE PAYING FOR A FERRARI BUT
WE'RE GETTING A BICYCLE WITH A
FLAT TIRE. I MEAN SOMEBODY TELL
ME. HOW MUCH CARBON YOU'RE
ACTUALLY REDUCE WE SPEND IN THIS
IN THIS IN THIS PROPOSAL WE'RE
GONNA SPEND FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR ONCE AGAIN. ON THE
TRAIN DOES THE HIGH SPEED TRAIN
. THAT'S THAT'S WHAT DRIVES UP
THE COST OF GAS AND DIESEL. AND
IF YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED IF THE
LOW AND EVEN WE TALK ABOUT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. IF
YOU COULD REDUCE THE COST OF A
GALLON OF GAS BY A DOLLAR THAT
HELPS DISADVANTAGED LOW INCOME
PEOPLE RICH PEOPLE IN THE STATE
CAN AFFORD TO PAY THAT AND THEY
CAN AFFORD TO DRIVE AN SUV. IT
THE SAP. ZERO EMISSIONS VEHICLE
SO TELL ME HOW YOU MEASURE AND
HOW YOU COME UP WITH THE
PRIORITIES BECAUSE THE
PRIORITIES ARE ABOUT REDUCING
THE CARBON AND ACTUALLY HELP IN
THE ENVIRONMENT. AIRPORT AIRPORT
CAN WE HAVE A RESPONSE.
CERTAINLY SO I'LL DEFERRED US ON
ALLEGATIONS OF COURSE BUT AS FAR
AS MEASUREMENT GIRLS WE TRACK
THIS VERY CLOSELY FOR EACH
PROGRAM WE SPEND A GREAT DEAL OF
TIME ENSURING THAT WE CAN
QUANTIFY ITS GREENHOUSE GAS AND
CRITERIA BENEFITS AND WE TRY TO
REPORT THAT VERY TRANSPARENTLY
EVERY YEAR INDEED RESPONSE TO
RECENT AUDIT WE FOUND EVEN
FURTHER CONTRACTED CALLIN OTHERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE REST
MASTERS CLEAN THERE IS THE
CANDIDATE WHAT I CAN SAY WITH
REGARD TO COST THIS IS SOMETHING
WE THINK A LOT ABOUT WHENEVER
REALLY CORE PRIORITIES PROGRAM
DESIGN INSURING THAT REGULAR
FOLKS. BUT ONLY GET ACCESS TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES FOR THAT
THE WHOLE TRANSITION IS JUST
CLEAR INNOVATIVE WE CAN BE
THAT'S ONE REASON WHY WE'RE SO
EXCITED FROM THAT WELL OVER HALF
OF OUR FUNDS ARE GOING TO
DISADVANTAGED OR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES- ON WHY WE CONTINUE
TO PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS IN
SMALL FLEETS ON ORDINARY X.
ALONE CAN KILL. I WE WORK SO.
WHEN SURE THAT. I'M SURE A
FEELING AT THIS IS DISTRIBUTED
AT. SO A HUGE. PRIORITY FOR US
THAT COMPLIANCE WITH THE BEST
WORK TRAINING TO CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT. AND I'M IN CONTINUE TO
WORK TO ENSURE. THAT OUR PROGRAM
JUST DEEP AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. AND DRIVE INNOVATION
SO SOME OF THE AREAS THAT YOU'RE
ABOUT IN TERMS OF. RESEARCH
INNOVATION HERE POINT I'M REALLY
GO TO THAT POINT TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE JUST ENSURING
THAT FOLKS HAVE ACCESS TO ZERO
MISSION CRITICAL TECHNOLOGY NOW
REGIONAL COST. BUT ALSO ON
ALLOWING US TO KEEP BUILDING
TECHNOLOGY TOMORROW AND HAVE THE
SHOTS BEING CALIFORNIA TO. GOING
FORWARD AND JUST ONE LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE ALWAYS REALLY
FOCUSED ON HONING HIS ESTIMATES
AND FOCUSES EVERY YEAR. AND THE
PUBLIC PROCESSES WE WORK THROUGH
WHETHER IT'S ON THE FUNDING PLAN
OR PARTICULAR PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT ONE OF THE FIRST
QUESTIONS ALWAYS HOW WE'RE
GETTING GOOD VALUE FOR MONEY.
OUR ENSURING THAT EVERYBODY
BENEFITS BY THE CHICHI CARE
PLANTS ARE TOXICS AND THAT WILL
LOOK AT THE WHOLE PICTURE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR GUIDANCE
ON YOU KNOW ISSUES WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT. HE CONSIDERATIONS WE
GO FORWARD SO I THINK IT'S A
REALLY GOOD QUESTION WITH
IMPORTANT PRINCIPLES TO IT.
MAYBE YOU CAN HELP US OUT ON THE
I'M NOT A GUN MISTER DALI
TECHNIQUE I SEE THINK US FOR
QUANTIFICATION SO IT WHAT WHAT
STE I THINK DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM HOW MANY METRIC TONS OF
CARBON WE COULD REDUCE WITH THE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION TO GO
CENTER WHAT IS AT WORK AFTER. A
DOLLAR PER TON. I CAN'T SPEAK.
TO THE DRINKING. PROGRAM TODAY
AND HAPPY HASSELT LOOK INTO IT I
CANCER. TO EVERY HOUSE GOT
PRODUCTION. FOR ANYTHING
PROBLEMS IN THE BUDGET THOUGH
AND GIVE ME A SENSE. EACH ONE OF
THEM COMES WITH MANY MILLIONS OF
REDUCTIONS. AIR POLLUTION SO.
HAPPY SHARE THAT WITH COMMITTEE.
IN ANY FORM IS USEFUL. I JUST HI
I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW FRUSTRATED
I AM THIS IS MY- THIRD YEAR ON
THIS THIS COMMITTEE AND- YOU
KNOW I DEEPLY CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND I'VE I'VE- FIVE
AUG I WILL NOT GIVE UP ON THINGS
THAT I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT AND
THEN I BELIEVE ARE JUST- WRONG.
WRONG ABOUT HOW WHAT'S THE
TRUTH. THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER
IS. YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE POLICIES
THAT COME OUT OF THIS THIS
COMMITTEE AND THIS LEGISLATURE
ARE DRIVING THE COST UP OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA. AND WHAT
WE GETTING FULL YOU CAN'T EVEN
TELL ME HOW YOU HAVE A THERE'S
NO PROCESS EVEN MAJOR HOW MUCH
CARBON REDUCTION REDUCING. I'D
LIKE TO KNOW FOR THE- YOU KNOW
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE SPENT SO
FAR. ON THE HIGH SPEED TRAIN TO
NOWHERE. HOW MUCH CARBON WE CAN
REDUCE I MEAN LAST YEAR WE HEARD
AND I'M ON BUDGET AND WE HEARD
THAT. IT MAY BE ONLY ONE LANE
TRACK NOW AND IT MAY NOT EVEN BE
ELECTRIC. SO THE I'M ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WHAT
WHAT WERE PASSED ON TO OUR KIDS
ARE WE REALLY DO SOME CARPET NO
WE DON'T WE DON'T COUNT THE
CARBON OUTPUT FROM FOREST FIRES
BUT WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE POINT
TILLMAN WE WANT TO TAX THE
PEOPLE WHAT IT WHAT IS SUCH A
NEW LOOK AT ALL THE SMOKE LOOK
AT THE AIR QUALITY IS COMING
FROM FOUR STARS BUT THIS BUDGET
HAS A COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN IT. FINALLY BUT- BUT
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT THE S. THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE COVERED IN
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER WERE SUPPOSED
TO HELP BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
THAT'S NOT VERY FAR. WE'RE GONNA
HAVE ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN
CALIFORNIA. REALLY LAST SUMMER
HE TOLD US DON'T PLUG ME IN
BECAUSE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE ISN'T
SET UP FOR. OUR LETTERING SYSTEM
IS NOT SET UP FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES SO MAYBE WE OUGHT TO
THINK ABOUT. THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SO WE CAN HELP ELECTRIC VEHICLES
BEFORE WOULD MANDATE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES FOR EVERYBODY. WE HAVE
A FAILING INFRASTRUCTURE WE WERE
WE WERE TOLD IN THE NINETIES AND
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN WE
SAW WHEN WE PASSED AB THIRTY TWO
THAT WHEN THE STATE PASSED SB
THIRTY THE FIRST. GREEN IN THE
LEADING THE WORLD CALIFORNIA
LEAD THE WORLD AND WHAT WE HAVE
. WE WERE SUPPOSED TO USE
NATURAL GAS TO BRIDGE OURSELVES
INTO. SOLAR AND WIND AND ALL
THESE OTHER CLEAN ENERGY I'M ALL
pHAVE SOLAR MORE SOLAR WE'RE
ACTUALLY PAYING OTHER STATES TO
TAKE OUR SOLAR AND ARE. BARLOW
DISADVANTAGE INCOME PEOPLE IN
THE MIDDLE CLASS ARE PAYING
THEIR ELECTRIC RATES TO PAY FOR
THAT MONEY TO GO TO ANOTHER
STATE THAT'S THE FAX. AND FOR
GOD'S SAKES GIVE US. A PLAN HOW
ABOUT A PLAN THAT ACTUALLY SAYS
THIS IS HOW MUCH CARBON YOU'RE
GONNA REDUCE. BY THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY CALIFORNIANS ARE PAYING
PEOPLE ARE FLEEING THE STATE
BUSINESS RIPPLING THE STATE THAT
MEANS REVENUE SLING THE STATE.
WE'RE NOT LEADING THE WORLD. STE
FOR SOMEBODY HAVE IT THEY HAD A
PLAN OUT HOW THESE ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO WORK. WE'RE TAKING ALL
KINDS OF MONEY IN. TONS OF MONEY
AND THERE'S NO PLAN HERE. I READ
TO THESE SEVENTY FIVE PAGES I
GOT LAST NIGHT. AND WHAT WE GOT.
WE'RE GONNA SPEND WE'RE GOING TO
PROMISE THE WORLD TO CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO DELIVER.
IT'S WRONG. I'M SORRY AND I
CAN'T TAKE IT ANY LONGER THIS IS
RIDICULOUS GIVE US A PLAN OF HOW
MUCH CARBON RUSSIAN REDUCE. AND
AN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
D. MISTER MISTER ROSS SCHOOL
WHAT THE ENERGY COMMISSION DID
YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON THE
ELECTION OR I GUESS OF THIS FUEL
PROGRAM ALL RIGHT I EVIDENTLY
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PHONE NUMBER
I HAVE TO REPEAT HIS SITES I
SENATE INCORRECT. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR- LET'S BEFORE WE GO. LET'S
GO TO THE L. A. L. BECAUSE I
FORGOT I WAS REMISS ABOUT ASKING
THE ALLEY- ABOUT THE GENERAL
DIRECTION THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON CAP AND TRADE IN THE
REVENUE DISCUSSION. MISTER BROWN
GOOD MORNING. MORNING THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROSS BROWN
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- SO THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ALREADY SORT OF DESCRIBE THEIR-
PROPOSAL FOR DISCRETIONARY CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN- OUR
OFFICE RELEASED OUR INITIAL
ANALYSIS LAST WEEK- THAT'S
AVAILABLE UP ON OUR WEBSITE- AO
DOT CA DOT GOV- ALSO THE- I
THINK THE LARGE MAJORITY OF IT
IS ALSO A COPY AND PUT IN YOUR
AGENDA TODAY. SOME SOME TRY TO
HIT ON SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
FROM THAT INITIAL TAKEN ANALYSIS
FIRST ON THE REVENUE AND
AVAILABLE FUNDS WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN TOPIC OF SOME
DISCUSSION- I THINK FIRST THING
TO SAY IF YOU WANT TO. BECAUSE I
WHAT I MISSED. IT IS THERE IS A
LOT UNCERTAIN AROUND. REVENUE
AND I'M- ALL THE MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE OR KIND OF AWARE THAT
. WITH THAT SAID WE DO THINK
GOVERNOR'S ASSUMPTIONS ARE. AND
YEAH THERE'S A THERE'S A WIDE
VARIATION BUT WE DO THINGS-
THERE'S LIKELY TO BE- ABOUT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OR MORE IN KIND
OF. A CAP AND TRADE REVENUE OVER
BOTH THE CURRENT YEAR AND THE
BUDGET YEAR- AND SO AFTER KIND
OF SOME OF THAT MONEY WOULD BE-
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED THAT
WOULD LEAVES. ROUGHLY SEVERAL
HUNDRED SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DISCRETIONARY
SPENDING SORT OF ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT THE- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ASSUMES- BUT I ALSO JUST
SORT OF REITERATE AGAIN THAT YOU
KNOW THESE ARE SUBJECT TO A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTY. AND WE WILL UP
BY COMPLICATED. REVENUE
ESTIMATES INFORMATION AROUND THE
TIME OF THE NAY REVISED ONE
SALES. I'M MORE UP TO DATE
INFORMATION ON KIND OF MORE
RECENT ARCHIVE. SUBSEQUENT
OPTIONS OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS. SO THE- SO THING I
WANTED TO ON QUICK AS- REALLY
MORE HONEST. SIDE AND JUST AN
ISSUE THAT. THE COME UP QUITE AS
MUCH IN THIS DISCUSSION BUT ONE
THING WE DO THINK THE
LEGISLATURE ONE I KIND OF THINK
ABOUT IS THE- CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS SO A LOT OF THE
DISCUSSION AND USE. AND CAN
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARINGS ARE
RUN AROUND THROUGH THE
DISCRETIONARY PACKAGE BUT WE DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO THINK
ABOUT. THOSE CONTINUES
APPROPRIATIONS 65% OF THEM
ROUGHLY SORT OF SORT OF THE
REVENUES CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED- AND SUPPORTING
CONNECT- DID YOU NEED TO THINK
ABOUT WHETHER THOSE ARE. THE
LEGISLATURE IS HIGHEST
PRIORITIES. MOST OF THOSE
CONTINUES APPROPRIATIONS WERE
AGREED UPON AS PART OF THE
TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTEEN BUDGET
PACKAGE OWN PRIORITIES CAN
CHANGE- SO WE THINK IT'S ALWAYS.
IMPORTANT THE LEGISLATURE TO
KIND OF CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THOSE- ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT- IN
A WORLD WHERE REVENUES ARE
HIGHER. AND QUITE A BIT HIGHER.
THE PAST TO WONDER ARE GONNA.
BASELINE REVENUE AS- CONTINUES A
PROGRAM. AND ROUGHLY TWICE AS
HIGH AS THEY HAVE BEEN IN MANY
GREAT. YEAR SOME SORT. OF THAT
MAKES IT WE THINK SORT OF MORE
TO KIND OF CONTINUE TO AT THOSE
THINK ABOUT WHETHER THOSE.
CONTINUE TO REFLECT WHAT
PRIORITIES. UNDER DISCUSSION
EXPENDITURE PLAN OF COURSE
THERE'S A LOT OF THIS ALWAYS
COMES DOWN TO. PRIORITIES
BETWEEN. THE LEGISLATURE NOT
PRIORITIZES GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS VERSUS LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION. AND OTHER FACTORS- I
GOT THINKING ABOUT THIS YEAR IN
PARTICULAR THINKING ABOUT HOW IT
SORT OF FITS IN WITH OTHER FUND
SOURCES THAT ARE OUT THERE THAT
ARE PAYING FOR MANY OF THESE
ACTIVITIES. AS AIRPORT WENT
THROUGH NOT A LOT OF MONEY IN
THAT ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE SPACE
FROM OTHER FUND SOURCES OF
THINKING ABOUT HOW THE-
GREENHOUSE GAS PIECES FIT
TOGETHER WITH THE GENERAL FUND
USES ANOTHER FUND SOURCES. THE
LAST THING AND I JUST WANNA
TOUCH ON REAL QUICKLY IS THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
ALSO FOR MOBILE MONITORING THIS
IS REALLY. THE ONLY NEW PROPOSAL
AS PART OF THIS YEAR'S- BUDGET I
G. R. F. BUDGETS- WE DO THINK
THAT YOU KNOW AND CONCEPT
BETTER. AIR QUALITY MONITORING
AND KIND OF BETTER INFORMATION
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OF AIR
QUALITY- IS- IS SOMETHING THAT
HAS. BEEN AMERICA- I THINK- OUR
MAIN QUESTIONS ARE WE THINK IT'S
REALLY COMMON CLEAR. WHY THIS A
PROPOSED APPROACH IS THE BEST
APPROACH TO KIND OF GETTING THAT
TYPE OF INFORMATION. SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS I THINK WE WANTED TO
FIGHT FOR THE COMMITTEE WHICH-
AND I WANT TO KIND OF- ASKED THE
ADMINISTRATION TO. COMMENT MORE
ON IT WHICH IS WHY IS WHY KIND
OF ABOUT THE SORT OF NEW MOBILE. MONITORING APPROACH RATHER
THAN. SOME OF THE OTHER
EXISTING- EFFORTS WE HAVEN'T.
LIKE THAT SIX. MY UP JUST OF
EXPANDING UPON THAT- WHY DON'T
YOU RELY. MONITORING RIGHT THAN
SORT OF STATION MONITOR. TO DO
SOME OF THAT WERE. AND WHY A
KIND OF FOCUS ON THIS ONE TIME
STRUCTURE- AND- YOU KNOW HOW HOW
CAN CAN GOT IN FOR. REALLY USED
AS OF MONITOR CHANGE OVER TIME-
THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE SORT OF
THOSE TWO. WHAT A WINE SO SORT
OF WHAT YOUR WHAT WHAT WOULD BE
GETTING FROM THIS ONE TIME
STOCKS ON HOW THAT HELP US. KIND
OF AN ON GOING BASIS. SO AGAIN
WE SORT OF YOU KNOW THE
SUGGESTED THE COMMITTEE KIND OF
EXPLORE THOSE QUESTIONS PERHAPS
IN THIS HEARING OR AND-
SUBSEQUENT MEETINGS AND IF YOU
KNOW DOESN'T REDUCE OR
SATISFACTORY RESPONSES TO THOSE
QUESTIONS BUT I THINK IT. MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER- REDIRECTING
SOME OF THE FUNDS FROM THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL TO OTHER.
EXISTING EFFORTS ARE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE HIGH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES SO. I WILL- IN MY
COMMENTS THERE ARE NONE. OF
COURSE. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU. PERHAPS WE CAN
HAVE THE ERROR- COM. ON WHY THE
- VICE. THE TO YOUR MONITOR
PROGRAM AND ALSO IN PAGE TWENTY
FOUR OF OUR STAFF REPORT WE TALK
ABOUT THE FOURTEEN EXISTING. A
COMMUNITY LEVEL AIR QUALITY. AIR
QUALITY MONITORING NETWORK SO.
WHY THE MOBILE ONE THIS TIME
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE EXTRA. X.
SHARE AD THIS IS AJ AT THEIR
RESOURCES WERE NOT HAPPY TO TAKE
THAT QUESTION SO THE MOBILE
MONITORING WELL LET ME LET ME
START WELL THEN- MONITORING IS
REALLY DESIGNED FOR A DIFFERENT
PURPOSE THAN WHAT. WE'RE DOING
AND IT MAY EVEN SIX ONE SEVEN
PROGRAM SAID THAT IN THE EIGHTY
SIX ONE SEVEN PROGRAMS THERE ARE
I NATION'S COMMUNITY AIR
MONITORING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
GOING ON IN MOST OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
SELECTED. AND THOSE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED BY THE
COMMUNITY STERN COMMITTEES IN
EACH ONE OF THE BURNERS AND
COMMUNITIES WORKING WITH THE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS. VERY VERY
HIGHLY TAILORED THE QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMUNITIES ASKING
THEIR VERY INDIVIDUALIZED I'M
PROGRAMS BASED ON WHAT THE
COMMUNITY WANTS TO KNOW- ARE
THEY CONCERNED IT HAPPENED ABOUT
A SPECIFIC SOURCE ARE THEY
INTERESTED IN BEING ABLE TO.
FIND OUT IF KIDS CAN GO OUT YOU
KNOW PLATE RECESS SO THEY'RE
VERY VERY SORT OF TAILORED AND
SPECIFIC. WE INTENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS REALLY DIFFERENT
IT'S REALLY TO GET A SNAPSHOT.
OF AIR QUALITY AT A VERY
GRANULAR LEVEL THAT STARTED A
BLOCK BY BLOCK LEVEL AROUND THE
ENTIRE STATE. AND SO THE GOAL OF
THIS IS REALLY TO JUST TAKE THAT
SNAPSHOT TO BE ABLE TO LET
COMMUNITIES KNOW WHAT'S THE AIR
QUALITY LIKE IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
IN THIS. ONE TIME SORT OF WAY. I
GUESS THE IS WHY- YOU KNOW THERE
ARE MY- THE QUICK THAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE. TAKING GET A THEIR
MOBILE UNIT AND DRIVE AROUND AND
GIVE YOU THE- CALL THE NUMBER
BUT CAN ALSO GIVE YOU THE
METHANE NUMBER WHICH IS WHICH IS
THERE THEY CAN GIVE YOU OVER.
TOXIC NUMBER THAT THAT'S THERE
SO THEY GIVE YOU A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT THINGS- AT THE DATA
THAT'S IMPORTANT MAYBE THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES NOT ASKING ABOUT IT.
MAYBE THE LOCAL COMMUNITY TO
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE A HIGH
METHANE SO WIDE LIMITED JUST TO
THIS ONE. MEASUREMENT VERSUS ALL
THESE OTHER TOXICS AND HAZARDOUS
AND METHANE AND CARBON NUMBERS
MAY BE SKY HIGH WHAT WAS YOUR
THINKING. WILL BE INTENSE IS
ACTUALLY THAT WE WOULD BE MORE.
FOR STARTED I'M GONNA CALL THEM
LIKE MAJOR GASHES POLLUTANTS.
FOR TOXICS AND MANY OF THE
SYSTEMS ALSO TO MONITOR FOR
METHANE SO I THINK THAT THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT COULD BE ROLLED
INTO THIS. OBVIOUSLY WE BEGAN TO
CHARACTER PROCESS TO DEVELOP A
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL AND WORK
WITH CONTRACTORS ON WHAT IS. IN
THE REALM OF THE POSSIBLE ON
THIS AND SO BUT THE INTENT IS TO
INCLUDE MORE THAN JUST. AND SORT
OF MAYBE IF YOU'RE THINKING LIKE
JUST OZONE OR JUST YOU KNOW
PARTICULATE MATTER THE INTENT IS
TO INCORPORATE AND- TOXICS AND
METHANE AND OTHER. ADDED AS WELL
. OKAY WE'LL BE PAYING ATTENTION
- LET'S GO WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY OF BC'S.
I HAVE. WHO'S MY PER. DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ROSCHMANN EITHER. FIVE
GOOD MORNING SHARED CHIU
FRIEDMAN HAS HAD TO STEP AWAY TO
ATTEND THE ASSEMBLY SUB THREE
COMMITTEE HEARING I'M VERY SORRY
TO SAY THAT MY NAME IS ANGELA
SOME ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR CLIMATE AND ENERGY- AND WORK
DIRECTLY FORTY FRESHMAN I'M
HAPPY TO- TO- ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. SHE DON'T HAVE A
PRESENTATION- NO WE WERE NOT AS
TO PROVIDE A PRESENTATION OKAY
FIVE THANK YOU FOR BEING THERE
LET'S GO TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN TAYLOR WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION I'M ALSO HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS BUT WE'RE HAPPY
TO BE HAPPY TO MAKE A BRIEF
PRESENTATION IF YOU'D LIKE.
BRING IT BACK TO OTHER MEMBERS
SENATOR STERN WE HAD A QUESTION
. TOM ON OUR CONTINUING
APPROPRIATIONS. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THERE'S SOME. I
DON'T THINK IT'S IT MAY JUST GO
BACK TO THE RESEARCH SUPPORTER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT- IT IS
ONE OF OUR CONTINUES
APPROPRIATIONS TO THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES FUND. WHO WHO'S THE-
RIGHT PERSON TO ASK A QUESTION
ABOUT SORT OF PERFORMANCE OF
THAT. FUND THUS FAR IN WHAT
WE'VE SEEN OUT OF THAT PROGRAM.
THEIR DRUG OUR PARTY FINANCING I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY PARTY-
FROM THE AGENCY ON THE DATE THAT
QUESTION BE COULD TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS BACK. THE ONE THING I
DID WANT TO JUST POINT TO WHICH
I CAN GET YOUR QUESTION-
ANSWERED ALL THESE. BELOW THE
ADMINISTRATOR BUT FELL AN ANNUAL
REPORT ON THE CAP AND TRADE
FUNDING WHICH ACTUALLY INCLUDE
OUTCOMES- ON THE PROJECT-
FUNDED. THE LEVEL OF GST
REDUCTION THE FILIPINO WITH THE
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY IMPACT OF
THE DIFFERENT SOURCES OR THE
DIFFERENT ABOUT THE FUNDING
PROVIDED EACH PROGRAM. AT THOUGH
FOR THE CABIN PRE FUNDED
PROGRAMS THERE IS ACTUALLY AN
ANNUAL REPORT THAT IT PUT OUT
PUBLICLY IDENTIFIED A LOT OF THE
OUTCOME OR THE SPECIFIC PROGRAM.
AND ALSO GET A LOT OF LIKE
READING ABOUT BOTH OF THE THINGS
THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE DOING.
DON'T HAVE DETAILS ON SOME OF
THE OUTCOME- WE'RE WE'RE
DEFINITELY HAPPY TO SHARE THAT-
BY WORKING YOU DON'T HAVE. I
THINK A SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT TO
SPEAK IT IN DETAIL ON THAT
PARTICULAR CONTINUE REPEATED
PROGRAM. OKAY I YEAH I WOULD
JUST IVU I SAW THAT. WHAT THREE
FOUR DAYS AGO I THINK EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
WAS AWARDED. UNDER RECENT- A RE
- ARE A P. TO. IT LOOKS LIKE-
FOR SEVEN DIFFERENT FOR ALL OVER
THE STATE- AND ACTUALLY WHAT I
WILL SAY IS I HAVE A I GUESS A
SIMILAR- MAYBE IT SOUNDS LIKE A
SIMILAR QUESTION BUT A VERY
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON ON THE
PROGRAM AND THE REPORTING THIS
FAR SO- TO MY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. YEP MY CONCERN IS
NOT THAT YOU'RE NOT TRACKING-
DOLLARS OR EMISSIONS I THINK YOU
KNOW THE STRICTURES BE PUT IN
PLACE IF ANYTHING- YOU KNOW PUT
A THE- OVERLY. AS WELL OVERLY
WAITING THE GREENHOUSE GAS
DOLLAR PER TON METRIC- THAT WE
USED TO SORT OF. BE OUR
OSTENSIBLE THESIS FOR SPENDING
THIS FUNDING SO I DON'T I DON'T
ACTUALLY THINK WE'RE NOT
TRACKING THE NUMBERS AND I.
WOULD REJECT THAT PREMISE I ALSO
THINK THAT YOU KNOW WHEN IT
COMES TO THINGS LIKE- COUNTY
FOREST CARBON- THAT THAT THAT
WOULD BE. A FINE FINE CONCEPT-
ESPECIALLY IF YOU WANTED TO
INTEGRATED INTO THE OVERALL
INVENTORY. AND MAKE THAT SUBJECT
TO COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS LIKE
THE OTHER REPORTING ENTITIES ARE
SUBJECT TO BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT. THAT NECESSARILY IS
IN THE INTEREST OF THAT INDUSTRY
AT THIS POINT SO WE HAVE NOT
SEEN THAT KIND OF PROPOSAL TAKE
ANY SHAPE SO I DON'T CONSIDER
THE SENATE- VERARCHING CRITIQUE
NECESSARILY OF HOW THE-
ADMINISTRATION OF THE AIRPORT'S
TRACKING THE DOLLARS I. THINK
IT'S VERY DETAILED AND
METICULOUS- MY QUESTION WAS JUST
MORE ABOUT WHAT PERFORMANCE WE
SEEN HOW MANY UNITS FOR INSTANCE
ARE HOW MANY BEDS WE THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GET BUILT OUT OF THE-
THE NEARLY BILLION DOLLARS WE
JUST SPENT AND HOW WE'RE DOING
ON A- SORT OF DOLLAR PER BED
BASIS NOT NECESSARILY A DOLLAR
PER TON BASIS- BECAUSE- LOWEST
DOLLAR PER TONNE EX. INVESTMENTS
AREN'T ALWAYS THE SMARTEST FOR
THE PUBLIC TO BE MAKING IT STUFF
THAT ACTUALLY PRIVATE SECTORS IN
A MUCH BETTER POSITION TO BE
MAKING. AND I OFTEN THINK WE
SHOULD BE REACHING- WE ARE IN
THE FUNDING THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING FUNDING AND THINGS THAT.
MAY NOT LOOK LIKE THE LOWEST
DOLLAR PER TIME BUT ACTUALLY ARE
THE BIGGEST GAP IN THE BIGGEST
NEEDS SO. IF THERE'S ANY WAY TO
GET SOME ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK ON
IT- WHAT WASN'T AWARDED DURING
THE LAST OF HSE AND WHAT'S
ANTICIPATED FOR THE FUTURE
FUNDING ROUNDS- THAT WOULD BE
VERY INTERESTING TO ME AND
ESPECIALLY HOW IT INTERFACES
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S. COMMITMENT
ON INFILL- FUNDING AROUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I THINK THERE
WAS AN ANNOUNCEMENT OF TWO
BILLION DOLLARS SO. MY QUESTION%
JUST FOR FOLLOW UP IS ABOUT HOW
THE CHSE PIECE WELL SORT OF
INTERACT WITH- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR SURE MORE INITIAL
TRANSIT ORIENTED AFFORDABLE
DEVELOPMENTS. AND WHETHER THOSE
TWO PROGRAMS ARE TALKING TO EACH
OTHER AND WHETHER- WHETHER ALSO
THE EXTREME HEAT STRESS. CONCERT
INTEGRATED SO ARE ALL THOSE ARE
TODAY PROGRAM TALKING TO OTHER
SO HOPEFUL FOR FUTURE. BY IN
WRITING HEARING WE CAN GET INTO
. IT WILL DEFINITELY REACH OUT
TO OUR OUR COUNTERPART- INDUSTRY
THAT PROGRAM AND I GUESS DIGITAL
DIESEL. I MISS IT. HI YOU'LL GET
BACK TO US LATER PART LET'S GO
THE SENATE MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR LOOK I KNOW
THAT WE'RE LOOKING INTO
CONTINUOUS- APPROPRIATION WITHIN
CAP AND TRADE- THE ONE ITEM I
JUST THINK THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED
TO BE ABLE TO FLAG AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. IS ON SEA LEVEL RISE.
AND IT MAY BE TIME AT CANDIDLY
IT'S PAST DUE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT SEA LEVEL
RISE. IN THE DOLLARS THAT MAY BE
AVAILABLE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PLAN FOR THAT CRISIS THAT'S
KNOCKING ON OUR DOOR. THANKS TO
THE LEADERSHIP OF CARE RIGHT
CASKEY IN THIS BUDGET SUB LAST
YEAR. THIRTY ONE MILLION ONE
TIME WAS APPROPRIATED TO THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. ON SEA LEVEL
RISE AND PROVIDING LOCAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS- BOTTOM LINE
IS THIS IS A DROP IN THE BUCKET.
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT IS GOING
TO BE LAPPING UP AGAINST.
COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN THE
CALIFORNIA COAST. AND THE NEED
IS BEYOND GREAT SO I THINK THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
FURTHER CONVERSATION ABOUT. I
KNOW THAT IT WOULD. ADD ANOTHER
PERMANENT CATEGORY. AND AT THE
SAME TIME THOUGH- THE LONGER WE
WAIT THE WORSE IT'S GOING TO GET
WE HAVE LITERALLY TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS CHEST IN
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE. LET ALONE
AND THE IMPACT IT IS GOING TO
HAVE ON HOUSING. AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WITH BUSINESSES
SUGGEST SOMETHING ALONG THE
FLAG. AND THIRTY ONE MILLION
SIMPLY IS NOT GOING TO CUT IT
BUT THE COST COMMISSION.SHORT
TERM ESPECIALLY LONG TERM. AB
OF. SWEDEN I KNOW WE HAVE TO
MOVE ON HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
L. A. L. ON THE IDEA OF A
RESERVE THAT WE WOULD USE. LET'S
LET'S STIPULATE THAT IT'S A
VOLATILE MARKET. NOBODY WANTS TO
PUT THE CRYSTAL BALL AND SEE
WHAT THE OPTIONS COULD BE LIKE
IN TWO WEEKS BUT IT IS RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER. AND YOU
SUGGESTED IF WE IF WE GET FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS OR FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS 210% RESERVE WOULD BE
FOUR HUNDRED TO. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE WOULD WE
WOULD YOU SERVE WHY WOULDN'T WE
TAKE THAT OUT OR STRUCTURE IT AS
PART OF THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION SO THAT THE
DISCRETIONARY NUMBERS. TO FUND
THESE. NEW PROGRAMS WHAT WITH
THAT WHY WOULD THAT NOT BE A
BETTER. ARCHITECTURAL STEP TO
TAKE RATHER THAN TAKE IT OUT OF
THE DISCRETIONARY FUNDS. I MEAN
I THINK A LOT OF IT JUST SORT OF
COMES DOWN TO AGAIN KIND OF-
PRIORITIES I MEAN SORT OF THE
WAY AS YOU'RE SORT OF I THINK
YOU'RE REFERENCING SORT OF THE
WAY IT'S SET UP NOW IT'S SORT
OF- YOU KNOW IF THERE ARE SORT
OF SHUTTERS. REVENUE VOLATILITY
THE CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS DO
LIKE OF REVENUE WERE DROPPED FOR
EXAMPLE THAT CONTINUES TO GROW
CREATIONS. DO AUTOMATICALLY
DON'T GO DOWN SO IT DOES SORT OF
HAVE A- BUILT IN MECHANISM THERE
WHERE IT KIND OF HELPS THAT SORT
OF BOTTOM LINE RESERVE. FUND SO
IT THAT'S KIND OF ALREADY. BUILT
IN THERE BUT THEN THE REST OF
THE STATIONARY PROGRAM SORT OF
YOU KNOW HAVE TO KIND OF HAVE A
RESERVE IN THE FUNDS TO KIND OF
COVER. IT WHATEVER THEY MIGHT
LOSE ANY REVENUE DROPS SO. BLOOD
SUGAR COULD SORT OF YOU KNOW
KIND OF- RE SHRINKS OUT I MEAN
THAT'S PART OF THE KIND OF
DISCUSS ANY ANY DISCUSSION THAT
MIGHT OCCUR AROUND CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS- I THINK A LOT OF
IT JUST DEPENDS ON. HOW ONE
WHICH PROGRAMS YOU PRIORITIZE
AND TWO IF YOU ARE GOING TO
CONSPIRACY APPROPRIATE MONEY.
MAYBE THINKING ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT YOU WANT. FOR THOSE HIGH
PRIORITY PROGRAMS WHETHER YOU
WANT THEM TO COME OUT.
AUTOMATICALLY GET A SORT OF
LOWER OR HIGHER SURE REVENUE
DEPENDING ON AUCTION PROCEEDS BY
KIND OF HAVING A PERCENTAGE OR-
YOU KNOW ANOTHER OPTION WOULD BE
TO ANNOUNCE. CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATE A CERTAIN DOLLAR
AMOUNT SET KIND OF WHATEVER
THOSE. HIGHEST PRIORITY PROGRAMS
ARE LIKE WE'VE DONE WITH- LIKE
THE LEGISLATURE IS DONE WITH-
FOREST RELATED- ACTIVITIES AND
SO THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS TO
CONSTRUCT. YOU KNOW HOW TOKIND
OF GET THAT REVENUE VOLATILITY
AND HOW YOU. CAN MAKE SURE
WHATEVER YOUR HIGHEST PRIORITY.
TARGETS TO THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT YOU'RE- THAT YOU TO GO TO
GO TO THEM- SO I THINK THAT'S
JUST KIND OF PART OF THAT BIGGER
BROADER CONVERSATION WE'RE HAPPY
TO KINDA- YOU KNOW PROVIDE KIND
OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THROUGH
WHAT THOSE PRIORITIES ARE AND-
HOW YOU WANT TO KIND OF MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THAT YOUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY PROGRAMS TO KIND OF GET
WHATEVER MONEY IS AVAILABLE. YOU
YOU ALSO RECOMMEND THAT WE
CONSIDER SETTING ASIDE A PORTION
OF. THIS FOR A FUNDING FOR-
LET'S SEE A REPEAT. TO ALL.
FOLKS MAYBE- REDUCTION AND RE.
ELECT RAY. WERE SOME TAX-
CHANGES. ARE YOU. WE DIRECT. A
IS A ABOVE THE LINE IS THERE CAN
. FROM THAT GO TOWARDS. GIVEN
HIGH PRICES. THE AND TRADE
PROGRAM UP TO. SIX SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS AT FOLKS YOU CAN BE HIT
OR IS WOULD THAT BE. A
DISCRETIONARY- ELEMENT THAT WE
WOULD FIGHT EACH YEAR WITH THE-
ASSEMBLY AND ALSO. THE
DEPARTMENT FIGHT. AND HOWARD HOW
MUCH IS HOW MUCH IS ENOUGH. I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE KIND OF
A RECOMMENDATION ON WHETHER IT
SHOULD BE CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED OR ARTIST KIND OF
DISCRETIONARY. SPENDING PLAN I
THINK IN GENERAL AS AN OFFICE-
KIND OF PREFER TO HAVE THINGS
DONE THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS BECAUSE THAT JUST KIND
OF BEEN SHORES. MORE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT- THANK GOODNESS YOU
KNOW CAN'T CONTINUE TO KIND OF
LOOK AT WHETHER OR NOT THAT SORT
PARTICULAR MIX OF FUNDING MAKES
SENSE BUT- COULD BE DONE THROUGH
A CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION AS
WELL AND I THINK THAT THAT. JUST
OVERALL RECOMMENDATION I THINK
GETS TO SOME OF SENATOR DOLLIES
POINT SURROUNDS- THE HIGH COST
OF LIVING AND YOU KNOW THINKING
ABOUT WAYS WHERE WE CAN KIND OF
STRUCTURE THE MIX OF PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE IN A WAY THAT. WAS
KIND OF REDUCE EMISSIONS AND DO
IT IN A COST EFFECTIVE WAY AS
WELL AS TRY TO OFFSET SOME OF
THE- OTHER COSTS THAT- THAT.
HOUSEHOLDS AND BUSINESSES ARE
OCCURRING WITHIN KIND OF THE
REBATE OR- OR TAX REDUCTION
STRATEGY MIGHT BE ONE GOOD WAY
TO DO THAT- SHE HAD A CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM. I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
MY COLLEAGUES BUT I WOULD
IMAGINE SOME OF THEM WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE THE ELECTRICAL BILL SAY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDED
THIS REBATE RATHER THAN THE
ENERGY COMMISSION ANNEX C. P. U.
C. BUT THAT'S- THAT'S TO BE
DETERMINED LATER- OUR STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD THIS
MATTER OPEN. WILL CONCLUDEOUR
DISCUSSION ON ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY FIVE MOVED TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX THE D. T. S.
C. GOVERNANCE AND FISCAL REFORM
PROPOSAL. TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NEW POSITIONS WE DID QUITE A BIT
IN THE- BUDGET REFORM SO- GOOD
MORNING- DIRECTOR- WILLIAMSON I
GUESS CHIEF- DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
DEGREE WITH THE TSC- A FINANCING
YOU WANT TO START OFF FIRST
MISTER AGUILAR AND GO TO.
DETAILS HERE. AVERAGE ME. FOR
THIS ONE- THE DEPARTMENT WILL BE
A THE AGE THANK THERE'S A LOT
GET THROUGH. GOOD MORNING ACT
HAS. RIGHT MY NAME IS MEREDITH
WILLIAMS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL THANK YOU TO YOU AND TO
CENTERS REQUIRE STERN AND DALITS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY. THE ITEMS IN OUR BUDGET
ARE INDICATIVE OF OUR CONTINUED
FOCUS ON PROTECTING THOSE
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
CARRY A HEAVY ENVIRONMENTAL
BURDEN. AND ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO POLLUTION. AS YOU
WELL KNOW LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED KEY
GOVERNANCE AND FISCAL REFORMS TO
IMPROVE DGSE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND FISCAL
STABILITY. WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE COOPERATIVE
WORKING RELATIONSHIP THAT WE
DEVELOPED WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROPOSE REFORMS IN PLACE AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THAT CORPORATION. AS WE
IMPLEMENT THE REFORMS. ONE OF
THE SIGNIFICANT COMPONENTS OF
THE FISCAL REFORM PACKAGE WAS
THE RESTRUCTURING AND RESETTING
OF THE FEES THAT SUPPORT EACH
YES HE'S WORK. THE FEAR IT'S
ESTABLISHED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET PROVIDED FOR THE FIRST
TIME TO STAY IN A WILL REVENUE
FOR DGSE WHILE SUPPORTING
INCREASES N OUR SERVICE. THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET WILL BUILD ON THAT
FOUNDATION BY FILLING GAPS
IDENTIFIED IN THE ANALYSIS OF
THE WORKLOAD IN OUR THREE
PRIMARY PROGRAMS. THAT ANALYSIS
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF PRIORITY
MANDATES AND ACTIVITIES THAT
WERE EITHER UNDERFUNDED OR
ENTIRELY ON SUNDAY. THE REFORM
PACKAGE SIXTY RATES TO GENERATE
AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TO BEGIN TO PAY FOR
INCREASED LEVEL OF SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA THE PACKAGE OF BCPS
IS CONSISTENT WITH LAST YEAR'S
REFORM DISCUSSIONS BCG'S THOSE
APPROVED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET AS WELL AS
THOSE PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE JAN TEN
BUDGET DOCUMENT HOW DGSE PLANS
TO SPEND THE ADDITIONAL REVENUE
GENERATED FROM INCREASED
FAVORITES. THIS ADDITIONAL
REVENUE IS A DOWN PAYMENT ON
BETTER PROTECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA. OF THE FIFTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS A TOTAL OF SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM
OUR HAZARDOUS WASTE. CONTROL
ACCOUNT AND TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNT WERE
APPROPRIATED IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AN ADDITIONAL
SIXTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM H. W. CA M. THIRTY
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
FROM TOSCA ARE PROPOSED IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. THESE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT CRITICAL PROGRAM NEEDS
INCLUDING PERMANENT FUNDING FOR
THE NEW BOARD OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY. EAST ENFORCEMENT AND
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
ACTIVITIES PARTICULARLY IN
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
INFORMATION IMPLEMENTATION OF
OUR VIOLATIONS SCORING
PROCEDURE. FULL IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM. INCREASES IN DTS HE'S
CRITICAL LEGAL I. T. AND OTHER
SUPPORT PROGRAM RESOURCE VITAL
TO DELIVERING DGS UNIFORM.
PERMANENT FUNDING TO SUPPORT
OTHER IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES
INITIALLY FUNDED FROM GENERAL
FUND LAST YEAR SHE INCLUDING OUR
CLEAN UP IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE AND
DEVELOPMENT OF A MODERNIZED
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT. THE
CLEAN UP IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE FUNDING
INCLUDES FUNDING TO IMMEDIATELY
BEGIN CLEANUP ACTIVITIES ON
TWENTY TWO OR FRIENDS SIDES WITH
A HIGH POTENTIAL FOR RELEASE OF
HARMFUL CHEMICALS. THERE IS
FUNDING FOR PERMANENT POSITIONS
TO SUPPORT AND ONGOING SITE
DISCOVERY AND INVESTIGATION
PROGRAM AND A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
INCENTIVIZES CLEAN UP AND
INVESTMENT IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. INITIATIVE FUNDING
WILL DIRECTLY BENEFIT
COMMUNITIES THROUGH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS AND TECH
TRAINING AND SKILLS DEVELOPMENT.
THIS WILL PROVIDE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WITH JOBS TO ASSIST WITH
THE CLEANUP AND REDEVELOPMENT OF
REMEDIATED SITES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION DEPENDS ON ROBUST
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COMMUNITIES
. THE HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT
PLAN FUNDING WILL ALLOW THE
STATE TO RE ENVISION HOW WE
TACKLE HAZARDOUS WASTE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE GENERATION AND
DISPOSAL OF HAZARDOUS WASTE
PRESENTS AN EQUITY ISSUE FOR
COMMUNITIES WHERE HAZARDOUS
WASTES ARE GENERATED AND
FACILITIES ARE OPERATED. THESE
RESOURCES WILL YOU WILL BE USED
TO CREATE A ROAD MAP FOR
REDUCING PERSONAL SOCIETAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS FROM
HAZARDOUS WASTE. FOR EACH OF
THESE INITIATIVES DGSE WILL
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON ITS
PROGRESS TOWARD GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
WE ARE EXPANDING ON THE
PERFORMANCE METRICS TIED TO OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN AND ARE
DEVELOPING DASHBOARDS AND
METRICS THAT WILL TRACK PROGRESS
ON THESE INITIATIVES. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO HEARING WITH YOU
AND OUR OTHER STAKEHOLDERS THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'RE MAKING ON
THE SPANISH. THIS FUNDING WILL
ALLOW US TO PROTECT THE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES TO HER
WERE ACCOUNTABLE. WE COUNT ON
CONTINUING OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AS WE WORK
TOGETHER SHE PURSUED
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FRANCESCA
NERI AND I ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT. OKAY
THANK YOU WILL- WE'LL GET TO
THOSE QUESTIONS LET'S MOVE TO
THE LA YOU KNOW YOU HAVE SOME
COMMENTS. GENERALLY OF. THE
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR IN THE B.
B. C. P.'S- PROPOSED. YES GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRANK MENACE
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- IN REGARD TO THE PACKAGE
OF PROPOSALS HAVE RECOMMENDED
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED A
PACKAGE OF REFORM IMPOSED
IMPLEMENTATION PROPOSALS WE FIND
THAT THE PROPOSAL'S ALIGNED WITH
THE EXPENDITURE PLAN THAT THE
APARTMENT PROVIDED LAST YEAR.
WHAT'S THE LEGISLATURE USE AS
THE BASIS FOR IMPROVING THE
GOVERNANCE AND PHYSICAL REFORMS
THAT WERE ENACTED LAST YEAR.
APPROVING THESE EXPENDITURES
WILL BETTER ENABLE THE
DEPARTMENT TO ENFORCE HAZARDOUS
WASTE LAWS AND NOT REMEDIATE
CONTAMINATED SITES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- AS PART OF THIS WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
USED BUDGET INSURE BUDGET
HEARINGS TO CONDUCT OVERSIGHT.
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
REFORM PROPOSALS BEING HEARD
TODAY TO ENSURE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S OUTCOMES ARE
LEARNING WITH THOSE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. EXPECTED ONE ACTING. THE GOVERNANCE AND PHYSICAL
REFORM. I'M FINE DIRECTOR THE
LEAD. TRACK BE OUTCOMES
REMAINING WORK LOTUS. WITH A
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION PROVIDED TO
THE APARTMENT LAST YEAR TO
ADDRESS BROWN FIELDS- INCLUDED
IN THE PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS
BEING HEARD TODAY ARE THE STAFF
NECESSARY TO CARRY OUT THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. SAYS THE
DEPARTMENT EXPANDS THIS FUNDING
BUT NEED FOR THIS ONGOING STAFF
WILL DECREASE IN THE FUTURE-
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRACK OUTCOMES
BECAUSE AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE- HAVE TO CONSIDER WHETHER
TO. PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO ADDRESS BROWN BUILDS TO MATCH
THE CURRENT ON GOING STAFF
THAT'S BEING REQUESTED.
REDISTRIBUTE FUNDING BETWEEN
STAFF AND- BROWN FILLED
ACTIVITIES SO- THAT WOULD
ESSENTIALLY PROVIDE A MORE
DOWNSIZE PROGRAM OR JUST
REDIRECT STAFF BINDING TO
ANOTHER PRIORITY SO TRACKING
THESE OUTCOMES OVER TIME WILL
ENABLE THE LEGISLATURE. AND PUT
IN A GOOD POSITION TO. MAKE THAT
DECISION AS- THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION IS EXPANDED OVER TIME.
I'M HAVING TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. I GUESS THE GAME
LET'S START OFF WITH THE BROWN
FEELS ALTHOUGH I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ON THE- ENHANCING
VIRAL PROTECTION FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL. AS YOUR
LEGAL STAFF. SO HELP IS CLEAN-
WHAT THE WHAT'S THE GAME PLAN WE
HAVE THOUSANDS OF THESE BROWN'S
FIELD SITES IN YOU KNOW. WHAT I
THINK THE CONCERN IS THAT WE DO
FOR REALLY GOOD AND THEIR
PRISTINE AND THAT THAT COMMUNITY
IS LOVE SAID BUT THE OTHER AREAS
DON'T GET THE ATTENTION BECAUSE-
THE L. A. TIMES AND PICKED UP AN
ARTICLE OF THE CHRONICLES NOT
WRITING ABOUT IT WHAT'S YOUR
GAME PLAN FOR ALL THE-
BROWNFIELD SITES IN THE WORKLOAD
WITH THESE SEVENTY SIX SIR.
THIRTY NINE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GONNA BE WORKING THERE WHAT'S
WHAT'S- YOUR ONE TWO AND THREE
HOW DO YOU EXPECT HOW DO YOU
EXPECT TO SPREAD ACROSS THE
STATE. I'M GOING TO TAKE THE
FIRST PART OF THAT QUESTION AND
THEN- PERHAPS FOR INTEREST IN
AGREEING CAN ANSWER. THE SECOND
PART OF THE QUESTION IN TERMS
OF. THE PROCESS OF INDUSTRY
YEARS GENERALLY SPEAKING THESE
CLEANUPS WILL BE CONDUCTED NO
DIFFERENTLY THAN ANY OF OUR
COMMUNITY WHICH IS TO SAY THAT
WE USE. STANDARDIZE RISK AT RISK
ASSESSMENT FRAMEWORK CHOI TO
DETERMINE WHAT. WHAT LEVEL OF
CLEAN UP WOULD PROVIDE ADEQUATE
PROTECTION TO THE COMMUNITY-
FROM POTENTIAL EXPOSURES TO ANY
CONTAMINATION THAT IS THERE
SOMETIMES CONTAMINATION IS IN
FACT LEFT ON SITE THERE IF THE
ROUTES OF EXPOSURE ARE
CONTROLLED WELL ENOUGH FOR
ELIMINATED- THROUGH THROUGH
APPROPRIATE MEANS. SO WITH THAT
IN MIND- THERE IS. YOUR POINT IS
VERY WELL TAKEN THAT CLEANING UP
TO- S. DEGREED WHERE THERE IS
ZERO RISK MAY NOT MAKE SENSE OR
WOULD NOT MAKE SENSE. IS IT CAME
AT THE EXPENSE OF CLEANING UP
OTHER SITES WHERE OTHER
COMMUNITIES MIGHT BE EXPOSED SO
. WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF NARAL
NEVER DID TALK A BIT ABOUT THE
MARKUPS TO WORK OVER THE COMING
THREE YEARS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE BEFORE
YOU TODAY CHIEF AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FRANCESCA AND ANGRY SO-
WITH APPLICABLE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE RE IN
ADDITION TO THE TWENTY TWO SITES
THAT WE'VE ALREADY IDENTIFIED-
WHERE. WE ARE ENGAGED AND CAN
ENGAGE NOW WITH THESE FUNDS IN
CLEAN UP ACTIVITIES WE HAVE. YOU
KNOW SITE DISCOVERING
INVESTIGATION PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE TARGETING TOWARD- DRY
CLEANERS THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY
HAD- RELEASES OF CHEMICALS-
THROUGHOUT THAT YOU KNOW THE
DURATION OF THEIR OPERATION. AND
SO AND THE REASON WHY WE'RE
FOCUSING ON THE DRY CLEANING-
SUBSET OF. THE SITE- THAT EXIST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CALIFORNIA'S BECAUSE WE YOU KNOW
WE HADN'T INFORMATION ABOUT THE
TYPES OF CHEMICALS- THESE DRY
CLEANERS HAVE RELEASED OVER
YEARS OF OPERATIONS INCLUDING P.
C. E. N. T. C. E. AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO BE FOCUSING ON A SITE
DISCOVERED INVESTIGATION PROGRAM
RELATED TO THOSE SITES AND
BEING. USED SOME OF THE FUNDS
FOR CLEAN UP WHERE WE CAN AND
THEN THROUGH OUR ANNUAL REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE IDENTIFY
CLEANUP COSTS FOR NOON OR FAN
SITE CAN MPL SITES- AND MANAGE
THE ONGOING WORKLOAD THAT WAY.
SO AND THE ARK WILL BE YOU KNOW
TO IMMEDIATELY ENGAGE IN CLEAN
UP ACTIVITIES THOSE ORPHANED
SITES WE'VE IDENTIFIED AND THEN
CONDUCT LIKE DISCOVERING
INVESTIGATION FOR. YOU KNOW A
SUBSET OF THOSE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
SITES WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
WHERE WE HAVE KNOWN
CONTAMINATION WE KNOW- YOU KNOW
HOW IT OPERATES HOW IT MIGRATES.
AND THE POTENTIAL IMPACT TO
HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AGAIN WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO MONITOR IT BECAUSE I
KNOW WHEN WE WERE CLEANING UP
GASOLINE STATIONS. AND YOU KNOW
WE DEALT WITH THE COOPERS AND WE
DEALT WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
BOARD AND EVERY REGIONAL WATER
BOARD HAD A DIFFERENT IDEA YOU
COULD HAVE TO GASOLINE STATIONS.
ACROSS COUNTY LINE AND ONE OF
THEM HAD BEEN. CLEARED THREE
YEARS AGO I AND THE OTHER IS
STILL TO MINOR AND SEE DOING TO.
ON AND ON AND ON AND I WANT TO
HARM PEOPLE BUT IT I THINK THAT
SUCH WE- A RICHEST. OF HAVING
DIFFERENT OUTCOMES WITH THE SAME
AMOUNT OF WORK AND YOU KNOW IT'S
A FULL EMPLOYMENT ACT FOR SOME
OF THE PEOPLE THAT MONITORING
WHICH IS IT'S JUST A DIFFERENT
ISSUE BUT WE'RE JUST STARTING ON
THIS AND WE'VE GOT LOTS OF.
DIFFERENT PROJECTS THAT. EVEN
YOU KNOW JUST INITIALLY GETTING
THE THAT HAZARDOUS MATERIAL OFF
THE SITE AND DISPOSE OF IS A
GIGANTIC STEP FORWARD SO- WILL
BE PAYING ATTENTION THAT ON ON
THE- ENVIRONMENT PROTECTION FOR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES YEAR I
GOT SIXTEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS.
CAN YOU SHED SOME LIGHT I MEAN.
WHICH COOPER ARE NOT DOING THEIR
JOB I MEAN WE'VE STREAMLINED
YOUR AGENCY AND WE'VE GIVEN MORE
MONEY TO DO THE WORK BUT- WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE EDUCATING THEM
AND THE COUNTRY THE BUSINESSES
WHO ALREADY. SHOULD KNOW WHAT
TOXIC MATERIAL THEY'RE
PRODUCING- TELL ME HOW THAT'S
GONNA WORK FOR ME NEITHER. THAT
SPIRIT HE'S BETWEEN SOME COOPER
SAID ARE DOING A GOOD JOB
ENFORCING THE CURRENT LAW AND
SOME OF THEM. IS IT A- RESOURCE
POWER TO DO NOT HAVE THE FULL TO
DO WOULD WERE SUGGESTED THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CURRENT. A LOS ARE. THERE ARE
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF REASONS
WHY- AND- BECAUSE- SOME
COMPANIES MAY STRUGGLE WITH
DELIVERING- THEIR PROGRAMS AND
IT'S DIFFERENT WORLD GROUP HAS
HAD DIFFERENT ISSUES AND URBAN
COOPER AS- AND SO. YOU KNOW WE
ARE RESPONSIBILITIES SHOULD GO
OUT AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY- ARE
TRAINED TO CONDUCT INSPECTIONS
AND GENERATORS AND TO- PROVIDE
THEM WITH- THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT THEIR
PROGRAMS WE DID THIS IN CONCERT
YOU KNOW THAT THAT- CALIFORNIA
BERMAN A PROTECTION AGENCY
OVERSEES THE COOPER PROGRAM. SO
WE DO THE SAME CONCERT WITH
OTHER BOARDS AND OFFICES AND
DEPARTMENTS UNDER KELLY PA WE
DON'T DO IT YOU KNOW
INDEPENDENTLY BUT- THERE IS.
THEY ARE- THEY'RE NOT MANDATE IT
THERE SO THERE IS A UNIQUE
SITUATION OBVIOUSLY SOME OF THEM
HAVE A LACK OF RESOURCES AND
OTHERS NEED ADDITIONAL TRAINING
AND SUPPORT IN ORDER TO SET TO
IMPLEMENT THEIR PROGRAMS
ACTIVELY. RIGHT IT'S NOT THAT I
CAN IF I CAN I MAY I WOULD ADD
THAT WE DO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
EVALUATES THE DIFFERENT COMPOSED
ON AN ONGOING BASIS TO SEE WHICH
ONES ARE PERFORMING WHERE
THEY'RE JUST FISH AND REALLY GET
A BETTER HANDLE ON ANY
DISPARITIES AND DIFFERENCES.
RIGHT I MEAN THE ACTIONS WE TOOK
WORK GOVERNANCE OF THE TSC AND
FISCAL REFORM IT WAS IN THE
UNDERLYING LAWS STILL BEEN THE
SAME SO THE COMPLETE SHOULD BE
EITHER ENFORCING THE LAW FOR.
YOU'RE DOING IT WRONG. CENTER
DOLLY YOUR QUESTION LET ME HELP
YOU. SO SOMEBODY FROM A RURAL
COUNTY WITH SO YOU DON'T HAVE
THE COOPERS DON'T I WAS A CASE
OF OUR SIXTEEN YEARS INTO HUGE
PROBLEM AND IF YOU'RE IN ALPINE
COUNTY. VERSUS SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY YOU YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
BUSINESSES TO SPREAD THE COST
EVEN HAVE THE REGULATOR IN YOUR
COUNTY. AND SO. YOU HAVE TO HAVE
ENOUGH BUSINESSES THAT ARE UNDER
THAT REGULATION TO HELP PAY THE
COST FOR YOUR PERSON THAT EVEN
GOES OUT THERE SO THERE'S MANY
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE. THAT
DON'T HAVE THE VOLUME QUITE
FRANKLY NOTS THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE
DISPARITIES ON. THE YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT PRACTICES BECAUSE
THEY'RE JUST THERE'S JUST NOT
ENOUGH BUSINESSES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO SPREAD
THAT COST AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
STRUGGLE- WITH ONE SIZE FITS ALL
LEGISLATION THAT COMES OUT A
YEAR OR- MORE REGULATION. ACROSS
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS
VERY DIVERSE AND IT AND IT AND
DOESN'T ISN'T THE PLAYING FIELDS
NOT LEVEL. SO THE SIXTEEN
POSITIONS ON THE BCP ARE GOING
TO BE SPRINKLED. IN THE OVER
WORK AREAS THAT HAVE LOTS OF
HAZARDOUS TOXIC. ACTIVITY AND
THE- SPARSE AREAS THAT WOULD
HAVE MADE SOME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BUT DON'T HAVE THE-
FROM VOLUMES TO- JUSTIFY. THE
EXPENDITURES AT OR AT LEAST A
LOOK INTERNAL EXPENDITURES. THAT
OVERSIMPLIFICATION NO THAT'S
THAT'S CORRECT IT'S TO IS TO
STRENGTHEN OUR SUPPORT OF ALL
COOPER AS AND SPECIFICALLY TO IT
WHICH INCLUDES SENDING A TEAM OF
OUR INSPECTORS TO RURAL COULD
BEST TO ASSIST WITH- THEIR
INSPECTIONS YOU KNOW SOME OF
THESE COUPLES HAVE- DISSENTERS
POINT HAVING ONE PERSON MANAGING
THE ENTIRE PROGRAM. AND SO YOU
KNOW WE SPENT TIME ON PROVIDING
TRAINING CONDUCTING INSPECTIONS
WALKING- BUT DOING IT SIDE BY
SIDE WITH THE COOPER INSPECTORS
AND I'M PROVIDING THAT GENERAL
SUPPORT AND- INFORMATION ABOUT
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL LAWS
THAT THEY NEED TO EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT OUR PROGRAM. OKAY I
KNOW IT'S A THE- JURISDICTION
WE'LL TALK WITH THEM- WHEN THEY
WHEN THEY COME UP ON MAYBE THERE
IS A NEED FOR. GOVERNANCE CHANGE
IS HOW THE COOPERS ARE ORGANIZED
TO MAKE SURE THEY DO THEIR WORK
THE MISSION CHARGE WHAT'S GOING
TO THE P. C. P. TWENTY FOR
PERMANENT POSITIONS FOR ILLEGAL
STAFF. AND I KNOW WE HAVE. I
WANT TO BRING UP A SORE SUBJECT
BUT I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN SENT BILLS
THAT THEY OWE MONEY TO T. T. S.
C. AND THEY WERE NEVER COLLECTED
FOR. YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS
IS. THIS ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
ARE THESE PEOPLE GOING TO BE
DOING. MMHM DEBT COLLECTING OR
THEY COULD BE. ASSISTING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IF THERE'S A
SUIT. OR ARE THEY GOING TO BE
GOING- TO. THE AT THE TRIAL TO
BE A- EXPERTS WHAT IS THE OFFICE
OF LEGAL COUNSEL WITH ANTI TO
SEE WHAT'S THE EXPANSION GOING
TO BE LOOKING LIKE. I WOULD SAY
THAT. THIS REFLECTS THE
IMPORTANCE WE PLACE ON
ENFORCEMENT AND MAKING SURE THAT
THERE IS A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
AND THAT- SH AND THAT ARE ARE
REGULATED COMMUNITY STAYS IN
COMPLIANCE AND THAT'S BEEN A AN
EMPHASIS FOR THE FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND SECRETARY. SH
I YOU NAMED QUITE A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT REQUIRE LEGAL LEGAL
EXPERTISE AND LEGAL RESOURCES
AND SO THERE'S NO ONE SIMPLE
ANSWER TO WHAT THEY'LL BE DOING
BUT- YOU KNOW WE DO WE HAVE. WE
HAVE A SENSE OF URGENCY ABOUT
DOING MORE ENFORCEMENT WORK MORE
INSPECTION WORK IN OUR- LOCAL
pGOING TO REQUIRE MORE ON. MORE
RESOURCES WE HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING OUR VIOLATIONS
SCORING PROCEDURES. PROCEDURE
WHICH HAS LED TO QUITE A NUMBER
OF LEGAL ACTIONS- AND THERE MAY
BE CASES WHERE OUR LEGAL STAFF
TAKES ON A MATTER INDEPENDENTLY
VERSUS WORKING WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE IT'S QUITE A
VARIETY- CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING
TO THAT I THINK YOU'RE I THINK
YOU'RE PRIMARILY COVERED IT WHEN
WE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH- YOUR
TEAMS LAST YEAR ABOUT THE NEED
TO STRENGTHEN YOU KNOW OUR
ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE AND DISPOSE
THAT'S JUST PART OF THE CALCULUS
IN PART OF- YOU KNOW THAT- THAT
A DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE FEES
WOULD COVER I'M TO TAKE MORE
TIMELY- ENFORCEMENT ACTION
REQUIRES YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE
GOAL SUPPORT AND ENGAGEMENT SO.
SO SOME OF THOSE WERE- YOU KNOW
POSITIONS ABSOLUTELY WILL BE TO-
SUPPORT- AGENT'S OFFICE AND
ADDITION TO YOU KNOW ALL THE
OTHER- PROGRAMMATIC. REFORM THAT
ARE INCLUDED IN THIS PACKAGE YOU
KNOW THEY'LL THEY'LL NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL- LEGAL SUPPORT AS
WELL AS AN EXAMPLE- YOU KNOW IF
WE IF WE- CONDUCT ADDITIONAL
TRANSPORTER INSPECTIONS AND WE
TAKE ENFORCEMENT ACTION OR IF WE
CONDUCT. ADDITIONAL GENERATOR
INSPECTIONS FOR THAT- AND
ENHANCING ENVIRONMENTAL- AND
PROTECTION OF VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THOSE LEAD TO
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS THAT REQUIRE
LEGAL SUPPORT SO CROSS THE BOARD
YOU KNOW OUR INTENT IS TO
STRENGTHEN OUR ENFORCEMENT-
ACTIVITIES. AND JUST TO REALLY.
WHAT A FINE POINT ON IT BUT IF
WE IN THE PAST AS WE DONE
TRANSPORTER INSPECTIONS WE SEEN
A VIOLATION RATE THAT'S
SOMETIMES AS HIGH AS 70% IT'S
THE NORMAL SWING HIGH AND SO
IT'S INEVITABLE THAT THERE WILL
BE ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS REQUIRED
AS A RESULT OF INCREASING THOSE
INSPECTIONS. I WILL ALSO JUST
SAY YOU YOU BROUGHT UP COST
RECOVERY AND- COST RECOVERY
STILL CONTINUES TO BE A PRIORITY
FOR US AS WE- AND AT A DOZEN
TALES SOME VERY COMPLEX LEGAL.
ANALYSIS AND- LEGAL RESOURCE. I
DON'T WANT TO OVERSIMPLIFY
UPDATED MISTER DALI BUT YOU HAVE
THE INSPECTOR GOES OUT THE
INSPECTOR SAYS SHE DID THIS THIS
THIS THIS WRONG. THEN LEGAL WITH
FOLLOW UP YOU KNOW AND SAYING
OKAY HAVE YOU DONE THE
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS AND THIS THIS
THIS AND THIS AND STAY ON OF AND
YOU'VE GOT TO FIND IT YOU GOT TO
PAY. AND PAY THE FINE AND SORT
OF COMPLETE THE- TRANSPORTATION
INSPECTION AND HAZARDOUS WASTE
INSPECTION. WHAT DO YOU SEE THE
LEGAL TEAM GOING IN THERE WITH
THAT. THE TALENTED GOD CHEMICAL
PERSON HAZARDOUS WASTE PERCENT
IDENTIFYING WHAT THE VIOLATIONS
HAVE BEEN. I DON'T THINK OUR
LEGAL STAFF DOESN'T GO ON THE
INSPECTIONS- IN SPECTOR'S DO
THAT THEY HAVE THE EXPERTISE
THEY COLLECT THE INFORMATION AND
DOCUMENTED IN A WAY THAT
SUPPORTS THE ENFORCEMENT PROCESS
BUT BACK SAID OUR LITTLE TEAM
REALLY IS VERY INTEGRAL AND
INVOLVED WITH OUR- CAREENING
INTERNS- TEAM EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY. IN THE SENSE THAT THEY YOU
KNOW AS WE DOCUMENT THE
VIOLATIONS. WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE TRYING THOSE
VIOLATIONS TO THAT TO THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE AND- ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE- YOU KNOW WHO
BASIS FOR OUR- OUR VIOLATIONS IS
CONSISTENT WITH- YOU KNOW DID IT
HAS GOOD STRONG LEGAL. DEFENSE
ABILITY AND THEN AS WE MOVE
FURTHER AND FURTHER IN THE
PROCESS THE BURDEN ON OUR- OUR
OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL BECOMES
MORE AND MORE- PRONOUNCED HAND
SO THEY END UP TAKING MORE MORE.
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
FOLLOWING THROUGH ON THE
ENFORCEMENT'S WHETHER THAT'S-
LITIGATION. DEVELOPMENT OF
ORDERS- SOMETIMES SETTLEMENT
DISCUSSIONS BASED ON SOME
VIOLATIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE MAY
HAVE SOUND AGAINST A CORNER. BUT
ARE THE ONLY. I A REALLY MINERAL
IN THIS PART OF THE YOUR
OPERATION. SIMPLY BECAUSE BUT
80% OF OUR- MARIJUANA GROWS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ILLEGAL AND- YOU
KNOW WE YOU EVEN FOCUSING I
THINK MAINLY ON PERMITTED
BUSINESSES BUSINESSES A GAS
STATION OR A- SOMEBODY WHO
MANUFACTURES OR THE COOPER'S
RAINBOW BUT HOW DO YOU- YOU KNOW
I THINK THE BIGGEST
ENVIRONMENTAL THE TRAGEDY WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IS THE POLLUTION
OF OUR WATERSHEDS IN OUR IN THE
ILLEGAL GROWS ARE HUGE IN
CALIFORNIA SO WHAT. WE'RE WHERE
DO YOU WAY AND HOW DO YOU WORK
WITH THE AG'S OFFICE OR D YOU
WORK WITH THE AG'S OFFICE ON
GOING OUT TO THESE BUSINESSES
THAT RE PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING
ILLEGAL BUSINESS OUT THERE THAT
ARE AREN'T IN THE PERMITTED
PROCESS AND LEGAL I MEAN THE
FRUSTRATION I THINK THAT WE SEE
IS A YOU KNOW A BY A FARMER SO
I'M REGULATED BY. DEPARTMENT
TOXIC SUBSTANCE I I'M MEETING DO
HAMMERED ON YOU KNOW REGULATIONS
AND REPORTING AND YOU KNOW
UPSTREAM FOR ME THERE ARE
MARIJUANA GROWS THAT ARE DUMPING
ALL KINDS OF STUFF ON THE GROUND
USING ALL KINDS OF CHEMICALS AND
THERE'S- NO KNOWN FORSMAN AND NO
WAITED LIKE RAIN THURMOND AND
THEY'RE ACTUALLY YOU KNOW DOING
A LOT OF DAMAGE TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT. REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR THIS ISSUE IS CONCERNED WE
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT IN. TO PARTNER
WITH. THE WATER BOARD OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE- FROM
TIME TO TIME WHEN ON SPECIFIC
CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES AND
ENFORCEMENT WE DO NOT HAVE A
SYSTEMATIC. EFFORT TO ON TO LOOK
AT MARIJUANA GROWS NOR DO WE
HAVE AN EFFORT TO REALLY ANALYZE
THE BOYER. WHAT BUSINESSES ARE
FOLLOWING FALLING UNDER
REGULATIONS THAT COULD BE
CREATING POLLUTION I THINK. ON
THE AMERICAN MARIJUANA ILLEGAL
MARIJUANA GROWS. IS A VERY
POWERFUL EXAMPLE BUT I THINK
THERE ARE OTHER SECTORS OUT
THERE THAT SIMILARLY HAVE- ARE A
FLYING UNDER THE RADAR. WITH
RESPECT TO- NOT BEING REGULATED
AND HAVING IMPACTS NOT JUST ON
COMMUNITIES BUT ON OTHER
BUSINESSES- AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THAT. LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
SOMEHOW. IN NEW. YOU'RE RAISING
A VERY POINT THAT- WE'RE HAPPY
GIVES ADDITIONAL CONCERT. ABOUT
INTO THE FUTURE I DON'T KNOW SHE
DOESN'T AND FEEL FREE TO ASK.
YOU KNOW I THINK YOU'VE COVERED
A- DOCTOR AND SO YOU KNOW WE DO
WORK WITH LOCAL FOR AGENTS-
OFFICE OF CRIMINAL. PARTNERS
WITH LOCAL ON AGENCIES ONE-
SITUATION BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION AND WE BRING OUR
EXPERTISE TO- THOSE TYPES OF
CASES BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE BRINGING
UP A VERY GOOD POINT THAT
THERE'S A YOU KNOW A LARGER
ISSUE- THAT WE DON'T HAVE THIS
YOU KNOW AND A COMPREHENSIVE-
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS. THAT
MEASURE JUST FOLLOW UP BY I'M
REALLY FOCUSED IN ON THE STORY I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIANS AREN'T REALLY AWARE
OF IN ITS IT'S- TRAGEDY- SO DOES
THE EIGHT. I THINK THE EIGHT SO
AGAIN AT. YEAH HERE WE AWARE
THOSE MOST OF THESE ARE. RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF- ENFORCING PEOPLE THE
LOCAL SHERIFF IS TAXED WITH. A
LOT OF THINGS AND DOESN'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES DOES IT AND WE'VE
BEEN PUSHING ON- LEASES THAT.
THE FOLKS IN THE NORTH STATE
THAT ARE I THINK. WE'VE BEEN
PUSHING FOR THE AG TO GET MORE
INVOLVED OR AND BRING SOME
RESOURCES ACTUALLY TO HELP OUT.
BUT DO YOU CAN EVEN COMMUNICATE
WITH THE AG'S OFFICE AT ALL. ON
THE ON THESE ISSUES. WE
COMMUNICATE WITH THE AG'S OFFICE
WHEN THERE IS A CASE WHERE-
WENDY TSC IS BROUGHT IN TO
ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
CONDUCTING AN INVESTIGATION
INTO. ILLEGAL ACTIVITY WE
PERFORM. YOU KNOW- A ROLE
CERTAINLY IN THAT INVESTIGATION
AND WE WOULD THEN ENGAGE WITH
THE AG AS APPROPRIATE- YOU KNOW
DEPENDING ON THE CASE AND WHO'S
HANDLING THE CASE AND ALL OF
THAT SO- SO IN THAT SENSE WE
HAVE CONVERSATIONS BUT THE NGOS
OFFICE- BUT I THINK. TO YOUR
POINT THERE IS YOU KNOW THERE
ISN'T A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY
AND- THAT TEACHES HE IS
PARTICIPATING IN. TO DO WITH THE
SPECIFIC CONCERNS. WITH THIS
SPECIFIC CONCERN AND SOME OF.
SOME OF THE PROBLEM ALSO- HAS TO
DO WITH WHERE THE YOU KNOW EAGLE
ILLEGAL GROW IS LOCATED SOME OF
THESE ILLEGAL GROWS ARE ON.
LANCE'S AN EXAMPLE INTO
SOMETIMES OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS
ARE CALLING US. AND TO HIS CHEST
ON OCCASION SO IT'S- IN ORDER TO
A VERY CALM- PROBLEM AND WE
REALLY ARE. YOU BRINGING UP.
THANK YOU. WORKING BETTER BROWN
FEELS THE L. A. O. PRODU THAT
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S
IN THERE IS GOING TO LAST ABOUT
FIVE YEARS AND THEN. PRESUMABLY
WILL HAVE CLEANED UP SITES IN
THE APPROPRIATION ARE NECESSARY
MONEY WILL GO DOWN DO YOU AGREE
OR DISAGREE WITH THAT- ANALYSIS. YES WE AGREE THAT YOU KNOW
WELL FIRST OF ALL I WOULD LIKE
TO JUST AND EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE
FOR THE PARTNERSHIP- WITH THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR AND- AND
FOR THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO CLEAN UP CONTAMINATED
OR TO BEGAN SECOND DESTINATION
DISCOVERY ANSWERED- CLEAN UP
CONTAMINATION VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES SO AS WE AS WE- AS
YOU KNOW I INDICATED EARLIER YOU
KNOW AS WE WORK THROUGH THE
FUNDS AND CLEAN UP SOME SITES
AND USE SOME OF THOSE FUNDS FOR
SITE INVESTIGATION DISCOVERY. WE
WILL BE- COMMUNICATING COSTS
RELATED TO CLEAN UP ACTIVITIES
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN OUR
ANNUAL- AND PL AND ORGAN SITE-
REPORT SO- TO THE L. A. AS POINT
OVER TIME AS WE IDENTIFY THOSE
COSTS YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
PROPOSING- WHAT THE FUNDING
SOURCES WILL BE FOR CLEAN UP
ACTIVITIES IN THOSE AREAS BUT WE
WILL BE COMMUNICATING TO THE
LEGISLATURE- WHAT THOSE COSTS
WILL BE TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
DISCOVER THEM TO THAT- TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SITE
DISCOVERING IMPLEMENTATION.
SCIENTISTS AND INVESTIGATION
PROGRAM. FOR ME BECAUSE ONE
THINGS THEY SUGGEST THAT WE DO
AN OVERSIGHT HEARING IT'S A
POPULAR THING FOR PEOPLE TO
SUGGEST THAT WE DO OVERSIGHT
HEARING CENTER CAN APPEAL HERE
IS THAT ALL THE MONEY OUT. I AM
SOMEBODY DOESN'T TELL ME WHAT
YOU HAVE AN OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY HEARING. DO YOU
THINK THAT WE CAN INTEGRATE THAT
YOU KNOW HOW MANY SITES THEY ARE
HOW MUCH WORK HAS BEEN DONE INTO
THE TO THE NORMAL WORK LOAD-
THAT WHEN YOU COME UP BUT GIVEN
THAT TO THE BEST THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. RATHER THAN HAVING A
SEPARATE. ANALYSIS OF THAT THAT
THAT BE AND- INTO THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE GOING THESE ARE THE SITES
THAT WE COMPLETED THIS IS THE-
YOU KNOW AVERAGE TIME YEAH THE
DATA THAT THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY HAVE. OKAY FORGET ALL RIGHT
THAT'S ALL I HAVE ON MY- BLESSED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
CONCLUDE THAT STAFFER CONDITIONS
TO HOLD OPEN ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SIX AND WITH THAT WE WILL CLOSE
AT THANK YOU AND MOVE ON BRING
BACK THE AIR BOARD AND A WEE HOT
THE OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH HAZARD ASSESSMENT ON
GOVERNOR'S BCPS ON RACIAL EQUITY
PROPOSAL. AND I HAVE. CHEVELLE
FLETCHER THE EXECUTIVE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OVER CARDS.
GOOD MORNING OUR STATE FINANCE
WANTS TO DO A PRESENTATION.
MISTER MERRETT DO YOU HAVE A
PRESENTATION OR- MISS FLETCHER.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO. KICK IT
OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OKAY
FORGET GO AHEAD PROCEED. I CAN
HEAR YOUR MUTE. THERE WE GO
BUDGET YELLOW FILLING ACCESS
LIKE IS IN THESE DAYS ALSO
WEDNESDAY GOOD MORNING AGAIN
GERMAN LIKE CASKEY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JANELLE FLETCHER MEMBER DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT OUR PROPOSAL TO
OPERATIONALIZE RACIAL EQUITY.
THE CARD IS REQUESTING ONE POINT
EIGHT FOUR SEVEN MILLION AN
ONGOING FUNDS TO CREATE AN
OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY FOR MANY
OF US TWENTY TWENTY WAS A YEAR
OF RECKONING WITH THE REALITY OF
RACISM PARTICULARLY ANTI BLACK
RACISM IN OUR COUNTRY. DESPITE
THE FACT THAT FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ENGAGED IN
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES SUCH AS
REDLINING WHICH CONTRIBUTED TO
LOW INCOME CANADIANS COLOR BEING
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXPOSED TO
HIGHER LEVELSOF AIR POLLUTION
THIS TYPE OF STRUCTURAL AND
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM IS
SOMETHING THAT MANY OF US DID
NOT TALK ABOUT MUCH LESS
ORGANIZED TO THIS DENTAL IN OUR
OWN POLICIES IN OUR OWN
INSTITUTIONS. FOR CARPET THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY AND A LETTER
FROM BLACK EMPLOYEES SHOWED US
THAT WE NEEDED TO ACT AND IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY OUR
BOARD SIGNED A RESOLUTION TO
THIS RESOLUTION TWENTY THIRTY
THREE DIRECTING CARD TO
ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY TO COORDINATE WITH OUR
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND ARE DIVERSE IN. RACIAL
EQUITY TASK FORCE. AND COMMUNITY
. TO IDENTIFY ADDRESS. AND ALL
OF ITS FORMS WITH IN CAR.
SERVICE OFFICE ONCE CREATE WILL-
OVERSEE ALL OF CARBS AFTER TO
ADDRESS RACIAL EQUITY. IN ITS
PROGRAMS POLICY AND RIGHT. IT
WILL HELP OPERATIONALIZE AND
IMPLEMENT THE CHANGES THE BOARD
DIRECTED THE ORGANIZATION TO
MAKE. THE FOLLOWING INCLUDES-DEVELOPING A RACIAL EQUITY LINES
FOR ALL OF OUR REGULATIONS AND
POLICIES. BUT INCLUDES CREATING
BOTH FORMAL SPACES SUCH AS
TRAINING AS WELL AS INFORMAL
SPACES JUST EIGHTY GROUPS. TO
ENSURE THAT CARP STAFF REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHY WE HAVE TO LEAVE
WITH REYES TO ADDRESS THE
NECKLACE. IT WILL ALSO BE
CRUCIAL FOR THIS OFFICE TO
PARTNER CLOSELY WITH COMMUNITIES
DEVELOP CLEAR GOALS AROUND
RACIAL EQUITY AS WELL AS
METRICS. TO ASSESS AND MONITOR
PROGRESS. ARBUS COMMITTED TO
REDUCE THE- EXPOSURE TO AIR. AND
RESULTING IMPACTS AND
DISADVANTAGED. AND LOW INCOME OF
. DO YOU INCLUDE LABOR TO
CALIFORNIA THAT CONTINUE TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY SUFFER FROM
HISTORIC ENVIRONMENTAL RACIST
AND OTHER SOCIAL BURDENS.
KRISHNAMACHARYA SAYS VITAL FOR
US STOCKS ALLIANCES COMMITMENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. GUESSED THE IN OUR
STAFF REPORT. CHALLENGES THE
AIRPORT ON ONE. THE PER OF THE
PROGRAM BE INCORPORATED INTO THE
PROGRAMS ANY ORGANIZATION SAID
EXISTS WITHIN FIFTY EIGHT WE
HAVE. THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION WITH
EXECUTIVE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE YOU HAVE
THE OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENT WHICH-
JUSTICE. YOU HAVE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TASK FORCE
THE COORDINATES COMPLIANCE AND
ENFORCEMENT OF EPA YEP THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PROGRAM
WHICH COVERS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. DESIGNATED IN THE
CAL SCREEN AND HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA JUSTICE AND RACIAL
EQUITY A PROGRAM WITHIN EPA ON
THE PROGRAM PRINCIPLES OF
FAIRNESS AND- THE CALLS FOR YOU
KNOW. OUR FAIRNESS REGARDLESS OF
RACE COLOR AND- WHEN CHRIS COLOR
NATIONAL ORIGIN SO YES WE ALL
AGREED THAT THE DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
WELL AWARE THAT WHY A NEW OFFICE
WHY NOT SHE IS INTEGRATED INTO.
THE. ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
OFFICES THAT WE HAVE ALREADY PUT
IN CARP. THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
AND SO I THINK I WOULD I WOULD
CLARIFY SOME OF THOSE POINTS I
THINK SOME OF THOSE OFFICES THAT
WERE REFERENCED ARE NOT WITHIN
CARP RIGHT SOME OF THOSE OFFICES
ARE WITHIN THE CALIPARI GA AND
SO I THINK WHAT WE DO HAVE
WITHIN CARP RIDES WE HAVE THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND- WHAT WE HOPE TO CREATE AS
THE OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY. AND
SO PART OF I THINK WHAT IS SO
IMPORTANT AND SO VITAL AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS IS REALLY
THINKING ABOUT AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE TRUSTING IN
RESPONDING TO THE COMMUNITIES OF
CONSUMER PRODUCTS I THINK MANY
OF YOU PROBABLY HAVE HEARD FROM
I THINK MEMBERS OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT HAVE REALLY
CALLED OUT CARBON SAID. QUITE
EXPLICITLY YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
SEE WHAT KERR WAS DOING ON
RACIAL EQUITY WEAKNESS FROM OUR
OWN YOU KNOW LETTERS BACK PLEASE
AS WELL THAT'S ALL WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THIS WORK WE'RE TALKING
THAT THIS EFFORT OF COURSE IT'S
DEFINITELY GONNA WORK CLOSELY
WITH I THINK HOW THE PA OF THE
OFFICES THAT THEY HAVE CREATED.
BUT IT'S REALLY MEANT TO FOCUS
ON WHEN WE ARE CARP DEVELOPING
OUR REGULATIONS ARE POLICIES
WHAT PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITIES
HOW ARE WE DOING THAT IN A WAY
WHERE WE ARE DISMANTLING AND
READING OUT I THINK I'M
PRACTICES THAT I JUST MENTIONED
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING RACE AND RACISM IN
ALL ITS FORMS. AND SO I WOULD
SAY THAT THIS TO NEED ADDITIVES
AND I THINK I CAN GIVE AND I
THINK THE CRIME AND I THINK AS
YOU ALREADY ACKNOWLEDGED RIGHT.
WE NEED THIS KIND OF TYPES OF
OFFICES MUZAFFER X. MORE THAN
EVER IF WE REALLY ARE GOING TO
BE SERIOUS ABOUT RACISM AND
REALLY ADDRESSING IT WITHIN OUR
OWN INSTITUTIONS BUT WHAT WHAT
DO YOU DO DIFFERENTLY I MEAN YOU
HAVE WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
NATURAL RESOURCES THEY HAVE
TWENTY SEVEN. OR THE AGENCY THE
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES
THEY HAVE TWENTY SEVEN DIFFERENT
AGENCIES THAT GO ON WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICE OF EQUITY RACIAL
EQUITY IN EACH OF THE
DEPARTMENTS WE HAVE THE RESOURCE
AGENCY HAS SAID DAVE. DEREK AND
CONTROL OF ALL THE AGENCIES YOU
GUYS ARE UNDER EPA I MEAN ARE
THESE- AS THE SECRETARY THIRTY
AS A CHARGE TO YOU SINCE YOU
KNOW THE ENVIRONMENTAL RACIAL
JUSTICE EQUITY PROGRAM THAT HE
HAS OF HIS. IF HE WHY WOULD YOU
I GUESS GUESS IF. A NEED. WHY
WOULD YOU NOT TO HELP SERVICE
PROVIDE TO CAL RECITE. WHICH
ALSO UNDER CAL WHY WOULD YOU
JUST SAY ONLY. GETS THIS. SIR IF
IT'S AN IN. SERVE RATHER THAN.
THE WHOLE. AGENCY IF THAT'S A
GOAL. I MEAN I DON'T SPEAK FOR
EVERY AGENCY BUT WHAT I WILL
SAY- AND HOPEFULLY THIS IS NOT
AN HONEST ANSWER I WOULD SAY ONE
AYE AYE. I BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW
CARVE AS A ARE RULES ARE RULES
TO IMPLEMENT RIGHT AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON I THINK
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND I
WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT I DO
THINK THAT WE NEED OFFICE IS A
RACIAL EQUITY ACROSS THE BOARD
AND THAT MEANS THAT I THINK YOU
KNOW WE DO A HAVE KELLY K. NOT
COORDINATING ROLE BUT- I WOULD
SAY THAT WE ALL OF THE DOUBTS
SOMEONE THAT'S LOOKING AT. AND
ASSESSING AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE POLICIES AND THE PROGRAMS
THE REGULATIONS THAT ARE COMING
OUT ARE ACTUALLY ADDRESSING AND
THINKING THROUGH THE IMPACT
THEY'RE HAVING ON COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT RACIAL LINES AND
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE IT I
THINK THAT'S WHAT COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN PUSHING AND CALLING
OUT AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING
I THINK YOU KNOW OUR NATIONAL
LEVEL WE'RE SEEING AT A
STATEWIDE LEVEL AND WE'RE SEEING
IT RIGHT NOW EVEN LOCALLY. AND
SO THE MORE THAT I THINK WE CAN
BE RESPONSIVE THE MORE THAT WE
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW IF
WE IF WE DON'T HAVE A FOCUSED
RIGHT NOW WHO IS GOING TO FOCUS
ON IT RIGHT NOBODY AND THAT'S
WHY I THINK THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
I WILL ALSO JUST KIND OF PLAYING
OUT THAT RIGHT NOW OUR CURRENT
YOU KNOW OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE IS HONESTLY UNDER
RESOURCE. AND OVERSTAFFED AND
THAT IS REALLY AT THE TYPICAL OF
MOST ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PROGRAMS SO THIS REALLY WOULD BE
I THINK IN SOME WAYS A HUGE A
MODEL FOR OTHER DEPARTMENTS
OTHER AGENCIES ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE SEEING I THINK THE
RECEPTIVENESS AND THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE LEGISLATURE BIKE WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THE SUPPORT GROUP WE
WANT TO SUPPORT THIS ONLY WANT
TO SEE OTHERS FALL. THIS MODEL
AS WELL. AND YOU DON'T THINK
THAT THE- ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE.
WHICH IS POSTED- IT RACIAL
EQUITY AND TO TRY AND CHOSE IN A
JUDY HEATING. AND FOR OUT REACH
AND INFORM PARTNERSHIP GREEK
BUILDING IS IN THE ATTIC TO DO
WHAT. I THINK I WOULD SAY THAT.
THE MORE RESOURCES THAT WE CAN
DEVOTE TO THIS THE BETTER I
WOULD SAY THAT I THINK OF SOME
GREAT LIKE SO I DO OVERSEE THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A STAFF
OF FIVE PEOPLE FOR AGENCY OF
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE SUIT
JUST TO PUT THAT IN THE CONTEXT
RIGHT I MEAN THAT IS. YOU'RE
ASKING LIKE FIVE SIX PEOPLE TO
LOOK AT OPTIONS AND THE THINK
ABOUT HOW I THINK SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE ARE REALLY
INCORPORATING IN ADDRESSING BOTH
OF OUR MAIL JUSTICE AND RACIAL
EQUITY AND ALL THOSE THINGS ARE
CORRELATED RIGHT THEY'RE NOT THE
SAME THING- THAT IS A BIG ASK
AND SO I THINK PART OF WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR THINK IT'S FOR
P. Y. I'M NOT EVEN PROBABLY
HONESTLY IN THE LAST. BUT IT
WILL REALLY HLP AND I THINK
SUPPORT AND AMPLIFY THIS OFFER
OKAY I MEAN WE LOOK AT THE
BUDGET WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
SPENDING 35% OF OUR OUR CAP AND
TRADE FUNDS INVESTED OR AND
CARPENTERS TO CATCH COMMUNITIES
WERE SPENDING OVER FIFTY SO.
IT'S SORT OF IMPLICIT IN THAT IS
THAT WE'RE DOING MORE THAN WHAT
WE'RE REQUIRED TO DO BY LAW BUT. WE HAVE CENTER DOLLY HAS A
QUESTION. PERSONAL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR- PRESENT TODAY I'M VERY
- WHAT'S THE WORD I I'M REALLY
VOTE IN ON THIS AREA AND I THAT
TOM HILTON THE CENTER OF HOUSE
CURATOR IS PRODUCTS. SOME POINTS
BUT- SOME I'VE BEEN TRACKING IS
- YOU KNOW WHERE WHERE THE MONEY
GOES AND- WHAT COMMUNITIES IT
GOES TO. AND YOU KNOW THERE WAS
SOME STUDIES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE- IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE ON
IT SO QUITE FRANKLY JUST JUST
BECAUSE- IF YOU FOLLOW THE MONEY
LET'S JUST PUT IT THIS WAY IF
YOU FOLLOW THE MONEY MOST OF THE
MONEY WENT TO. PLACES LIKE THE
BAY AREA. MOST THE MAJORITY OF
MONEY ONE OF THE BAY AREA VERSUS
PLACES LIKE. FRESNO AND SALINAS
AND PLACES WHERE WE HAVE LIKE
REALLY. A HIGHER CONCENTRATION
OF POLLUTION AND THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE ALL UP FOR AND
SO I WILL MY QUESTION TO YOU IS-
WHAT WHAT IS THE WHAT'S THE PLAN
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO THE MALL A-
GAUGE IT AND HOW ARE YOU WHAT
WHAT IS THE OUTCOMES THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR OBVIOUSLY- WE WANT
TO SEE. A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- HAVE THE SAME EQUAL
FOOTING AS OTHER COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE AND IT'S QUITE FRANKLY
NOT THAT WAY- IN ALL GIVEN
EXAMPLE IS A LOT OF IT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT. ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ARE WAS YOU KNOW MANY TAX
CREDITS GIVEN OUT FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. AND WE SAW THE MOST
THOSE TAX CREDITS GO TO
WEALTHIER PEOPLE THAT COULD
AFFORD TO BUY- DESERVES LUXURY
VEHICLES AND THE POOR PEOPLE
DIDN'T SO MUCH. AND THE REASON
BEING IS THAT. WEALTHY PEOPLE
CAN AFFORD THOSE KIND OF CARS
AND THEY HAD THE ACCESS TO
CHARGING STATIONS AND OTHER
THINGS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
THAT- MANY FOLKS IN THE- IN THE
MORE POOR COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WERE ABLE TO- TAKE
TAKE THAT THE SAME. OPPORTUNITY
SO CAN YOU KIND OF GIVE ME A
LIKE A LAYOUT PLAN WHAT WHAT YOU
THINK THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE IN
THIS AREA. ABSOLUTELY AND I
THINK I'M IN TERMS OF LIKE THE
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS RIGHT ALL
ALL TO FORGET TO DO I FIND THAT
BUT I ACTUALLY. COMPLETELY AGREE
SENATOR WITH I THINK WE ARE
ASSESSMENT IS RIGHT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- ZADZIM TALKING
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE SEEING AND
I THINK WE HEAR FROM THE
COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW. IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW HOW OR IF THE FORD
ABILITY RIGHT SORT OF LED AND
ACCESSIBILITY I THINK ARE KEY
POINTS I KNOW THAT WHEN I AM. A
FELLOW DEPUTY CRACK ALSO ABOUT
THOSE PLANS AS WELL SO THAT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS OFFICE
OF RACIAL EQUITY ABSOLUTELY WHAT
WE WANT TO SEE WHAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT. IS HOW ARE WE
MAKING SURE AS THESE POLICIES
ARE ROLLING OUT RIGHTS AS WE'RE
GETTING KIND OF LIKE THESE-
THESE CLEAR MANDATES AROUND
STATUS AND WHAT WE WANT TO SEE
HAPPEN. HOW ARE WE MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE KIND
OF FUN CENTER RECEIVING THOSE
BENEFITS AND THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
REDUCING THE BURDENS AROUND LIKE
ACCESS AND COST AFFORDABILITY
FOR THEM. AND SO TO ME PART OF
WHAT'S BEAUTIFUL ABOUT HOW TO
GET OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY WITH
AND CARP WHICH IS THAT WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY AND WE ARE
MAKING SURE THAT THE POLICIES
ARE BEING DEVELOPED WE REALLY DO
YOU HAVE THAT RACIAL EQUITY
LANDS RIGHT WE'RE LOOKING AT.
IMPACTS LOOKING AT BURDENS WILL
GET UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES I
WOULD BE ON TOP OF THAT WE
REALLY DO HAVE A ROBUST
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
WHERE I THINK YOU KNOW OUR OUR
STAFF ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
COMMUNITIES TO SHAPE AND DEVELOP
THESE. AND THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT THAT THAT'S NOT HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
THE OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY WHAT
IT REALLY DOES IS REALLY HELP TO
KIND OF REALLY FOCUSING THOSE
EFFORTS AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A CLEAR. TRANSPARENT
PROCESS BUT I THINK YOU KNOW
SENATORS HERE AS WELL AS
COMMUNITIES CAN UNDERSTAND IN
TRACK AND SEE. EXACTLY WHAT WE
ARE DOING ON THAT FRONT. WELL I
WILL BE. FOLLOW THIS VERY
CLOSELY. SOME I'M DEFINITELY
PASSIONATE. IN THE BILITY TO BE
ABLE TO- TRACTOR FOR. AND WHO.
AND THERE'S TWO WAY TO LOOK. IT
EITHER. YOU KNOW IT THE COST OF
LIVING IS SKYROCKETING
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ACTUALLY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SO THOSE JUST OF
ENGINEERS ARE PAYING. 60%
HIGHER. ELECTRICITY RATES IS
SOMETHING I TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER. AND ALSO PAYING. A LOT
MORE FOR THEIR FUEL- AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE INCOME. THAT
OTHER P. SOME OTHER PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE THAT ARE
BENEFITING. AND SO. THESE
PROGRAMS ALL OF WHAT WE DO IT.
AT CAL IN THE LEADING CALIFORNIA
IN THE WORLD IN CLIMATE CHANGE
DRIVE UP THE COST OF LIVING. FOR
DISADVANTAGED FOLKS NOW SOME
PEOPLE THAT ARE WEALTHY CAN
OFFSET THAT AND THEY CAN LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA THEY FEEL GOOD ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHERE WE'RE HEADED WITH
THE CLIMATE BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY IF WE- ARE NOT TAKING A
CLOSE LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY. TO THE- LOW INCOME AND
THE MIDDLE CLASS FOLKS. THAT
HAVE TO QUITE FRANKLY COMMUTE
FURTHER TO THEIR JOBS. AND LIVE
IN POOR COMMUNITIES- THAT'S NOT
FAIR AND THEY'RE GETTING THEY'RE
PAYING THE BILL NOT MAY BE
DIRECTLY- BUT THEY'RE PAINTED
INDIRECTLY THROUGH. THE
REGULATIONS THAT DRIVE UP THE
COST OF LIVING AND SO- I'M THIS
IS AN AREA THAT I THINK IS. NOT
THE TRUTH IS NOT REALLY LAID OUT
VERY. MAINLY IN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT. WHO'S PAYING AND WHOSE
BENEFITING. AND THE NUMBERS THAT
WE'VE SEEN OR THE WEALTHY ARE
BENEFITING MORE THAN THE THAN A
NON WEALTHY- AND SO I JUST AND
WOULD WANT TO SAY TO YOU THAT
TIME THIS IS MERRY I THINK THAT.
THAT NEEDS DAYLIGHT A LOT OF
DAYLIGHT AND- I'M GONNA BE FONG
NECESSARY BECAUSE I THINK IT'S-
NOT FAIR IT'S NOT FAIR TO THE
PEOPLE THAT. ARE ACROSS THE
BOARD PAYING THE BILL AND NOT
GETTING THE BANDAGE OF. THE
PERKS THAT COME OUT OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND IN REWARDS TO
GETTING. US GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WITH CLIMATE. OKAY I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER HANDS I
GUESS. I WANTED WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THIS MATTER I
GUESS ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WORK TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IS
THAT EARLIER TODAY ON ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE WE HAD CAP
AND TRADE AND WE HAD CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL. CLEANS CARPETS FOR ALL
WE PUT FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION IN FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
PROTECT THAT ATTEMPT TO IMPROVE
RACIAL EQUITY RIGHT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ASKING FOR
SEVENTY SIX MILLION MORE ON TOP
OF THAT FOR THIS PROGRAM. IS THE
OFFICE OF IS THE OFFICE THAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING IS THAT GOING
TO MONITOR THAT IS OR SOMETHING
OUR PEOPLE THE PICK THE
PARTICIPANTS ARE YOU SOON ARE
MEET ALL THE CATEGORY RIGHT THE
ARE LOW INCOME THEY- THERE LIVE
IN A NON. AREA ECCENTRICS YOU
SEE THAT THIS OFFICE SOMEHOW
GOING TO MONITOR. THE OTHER. ALL
THE PRO. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE DOING IT RIGHT. IF I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I HATE
THAT I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION
SENATOR ARE YOU ASKING ME. IN
RELATION TO I THINK THAT- THE
CAP AND TRADE B. C. Q. THAT WE
SHARED ARE YOU ASKING ME IF THE
OFFICE OF RACIAL LIKELY WE WILL
BE MONITORING. THE ACTIVITIES
THAT WE OUTLINED IN THE CAP AND
TRADE B. C. P. MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S ACTUALLY BEING EQUITABLE.
RABY YOU'RE THE SUGGESTION AS WE
NEED THIS NEW PROGRAM TO
OPERATIONALIZE RACIAL EQUITY SO
WE HAVE A PROGRAM THAT'S ALREADY
DESIGNED FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE
DISADVANTAGED MANY RACIAL EQUITY
WITHIN WITHIN KERR. SAID THERE
COULD BE THE VANCE RACIAL EQUITY
EFFORTS HOW WOULD BE A SYSTEM
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE THE PROGRAM
JUST IT'S JUST PICKING THAT
PROGRAM. IF THE CONCERN IS THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH. OR
THERE'S A QUALITY. I'M SO SORRY
I THINK I CAN WITH WHICH I'M SO
SORRY WHICH PROGRAM THIS IS
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL. CREEK CLEAN
CARS FALL CALPERS FOR ALL TO BE
GENERATED IT'S RUN BY CAR IT'S
ONLY A LIMITED GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT PARTICIPATE IN IT WHAT
WOULD THIS. ADDITIONAL
MONITORING THAT CAR. NOT NOT
DEALING WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
THE EPA MONITORING HOW IT IS
HERE IT LEVEL OF REDUNDANCY I
GUESS I'M- ASKING. GASTAUT I GOT
IT SORRY ABOUT THAT THAT WAS
HELPFUL SO I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WOULD PROBABLY
JUST KIND OF THAT TO UNDERSCORE
IS THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY FOR US IT'S MUCH BIGGER
RATE THAN JUST THE G. CARE ACT
PROGRAMS AND- AND SO YOU KNOW
YES YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE
DO HAVE A YOU KNOW CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL. AND THERE IS THAT
PROGRAM WE HAVE OTHER PROGRAMS
WITH THEM LIKE RIGHT THE TEACHER
OF THE WEEK WE TALKED ABOUT HOW
WE HAVE EIGHTY SIX DEGREES WE
HAVE THESE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
REALLY FOCUSED ON AND THINKING
ABOUT EQUITY AND HOW DO WE
OPERATIONALIZE THAT- MORE
TALKING ABOUT THE OFFICE OF
RACIAL EQUITY WE REALLY DO YOU
THINK ABOUT IT'S MUCH BIGGER AND
MUCH LARGER IN SCOPE. ONLY THINK
ABOUT IT AS A PLACE WHERE WE
REALLY ARE THINKING ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR RANKS ABOUT
MID OF OUR POLICIES OUR SHIPPING
OUR OWN CULTURE INTERNALLY WITH
OUR STAFF OUR BUILDING THAT
COMPETENCY AND UNDERSTANDING
AROUND RACIAL EQUITY AND HOW
WE'RE PARTNERING WITH
COMMUNITIES AND SO I THINK THAT
IN SOME WAYS I WOULD SAY IT'S
JUST. DIFFERENT THAN TO WHAT
WE'RE DOING I THINK IN TERMS OF
THE G. CARE ACT BECAUSE YES
RIGHT THERE IS A POINT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW WITH-
YEAH OFFICE RACIAL EQUITY BEING
VERY TRANSPARENT AND CLEAR AND
HOW WE GET CARP ARE ASSESSING
FOR RACIAL EQUITY WITHIN OUR
REGULATIONS ON WITHIN OUR
PROGRAMS AND THAT WILL LEAD TO
KIND OF GREATER TRANSPARENCY I
THINK RIGHT NOW BUT THE
LEGISLATURE FOR COMMUNITIES. AND
I THINK IT'S MUCH QUICKER AND
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW ARE WE
DEVELOPING OUR RAGS HOW ARE WE
THINKING ABOUT FROM THE FRONT
AND ABOUT BURDENS CONSEQUENTLY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IMPACTS.
THOSE PIECES RIGHT I THINK BY
DOING THAT WORK RIGHT THAT'S
ALSO GOING TO GRADUATION I COULD
BE THINKING ABOUT OUR STAFF
MAKING ABOUT PEOPLE THAT WERE%
BREAK AGAIN AND HOW REBUILDING A
CULTURE WHERE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE TO BE A
GREAT RACE THESE ARE HISTORIC
INEQUITIES THAT OUR OWN COUNTRY
HAS A PICTURE HIT IT RIGHT AT
ITS STATE LEVEL FEDERAL LEVEL.
AT A LOWER LEVEL AND WHAT DOES
IT LOOK LIKE DISPENSED BY AS A
COVER AGENCY I THINK I'M TO KIND
OF PAINT THE PICTURE OF IS THAT
YES ABSOLUTELY BECAUSE THAT THE
PROJECT THAT WE HAVE A MOST AND
THAT FOR US THIS IS A FAR AWAY.
IN SCOPE AND REALLY KIND OF COST
YOU A LOT OF LIKE I SAID THE
RESTRUCTURING WE'VE SEEN THAT
HAPPENING AT THE NATIONAL. LEVEL
AND HOW IS THAT DIFFERENT FROM
THE OFFICE OF AND FOR. JUSTICE
DPA. BECAUSE AGAIN YOU'VE GOT.
AB SIX ONE SEVEN WE GOT WE'RE
GOING. WE'RE DOING SURE READ
WITH THE CAN. WERE TO CA. CAN
THEIR INPUT. HE TRANSFORM
CLIMATE. OF VISIBILITY. CHARETTE
THAT WERE. OUT TO TALK WITH
COMPARE AND FORTH. AND IT SEEMS
AS THOUGH. AT LEAST PEOPLE. ARE
HAPPY. THOSE I MEAN. WHETHER
SPENDING ENOUGH MONEY OR- THAT.
SHE COME OUT AND- GIGI ARE F. IS
A DIFFERENT. BUT THE OFFICE OF
AN- JUSTICE. WHY CAN'T THEY DO
THAT WHY IS THAT WHAT WILL BE
DIFFERENT I GUESS. RIGHT IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION SO I THINK I'M
AND I'LL I'LL SAY REALLY GREAT
SO I CAN'T SPEAK. LAST WEEK THAT
TENANTS ARE COMING COMMUNITIES
LETTER OR ORDER TO CUT DOWN- AND
I ALLOCATE DOES HAVE ITS OWN
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE FOR BUT I
CAN SPEAK TO I THINK OFFICE
BAYERN JUSTICE KERR. OR
SOMETHING THAT I DO I OVER- AND
WE I WOULD SAY IS EXACTLY POINT
FOR YOUR SAYING RIGHT ARE WITH
THAT THERE HAVE WITH THE EFFORTS
THAT WERE DEALING. AT THE SAME
TIME. I'LL COMMITTEE CAN A THAT
POINT THAT HAVING PEOPLE FOR A
STAFF OF SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE FOCUS ON ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HEARING AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
SEEN AND ADDRESSED ME WHY CASE
IN POINT. THOSE FIVE STAFF
BETWEEN EMAIL AND BASICALLY LIKE
BEING A KIND OF CONVENER FOR
EIGHTY THIRTY TO ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
RETURNING ARE KIND OF COMMUNITY
AIRCRAFT PROGRAM BETWEEN KIND OF
OVERSEEING OUR BORDER EFFORTS AT
CARP. AND THEN I THINK NOW
CLEARLY OUR TRIBAL EFFORTS AS
WELL I MEAN THAT RIGHT THERE
ALONE TAKES UP. A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE YOU KNOW TEAM IS DOING
AND I THINK ON TOP OF THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING OUT
COMMUNITIES KIND OF LIKE
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE'RE
BUILDING UP RELATIONSHIPS HAVING
TOWARDS. SO PART OF WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY TO DO AGAIN I THINK IT'S
REALLY ADDED AFTER WHAT YOU ARE
SHARED. IS REALLY THINK ABOUT
COMPREHENSIVELY HOW ARE WE
ANALYZING ASSESSING. RACIAL
EQUITY WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE IT
WHAT DOES IT MEAN OVERTOPPING
OUR RAGS TO ACTUALLY THINK
THROUGH THE IMPACT FROM THE
BURDENS AT THE FRONT END WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TO HAVE CLEAR
METRICS CLEAR GOALS AROUND HERE
IS WHAT WE ARE CARP. ARE GOING
TO DO YOUR EQUITY THIS IS OUR
KIND OF OUR PLAN HERE THE
MEASURE THAT YOU CAN TRACK AND
WAS LOOK LIKE FOR US TO KIND OF
CONTINUALLY UPDATE BUT THE
COMMAND WHICH LATER ON NOT. AND
SO I CAN'T I REALLY DO YOU SEE
THIS IS REALLY ADDITIVE TO WORK
THAT WERE ALREADY DOING BOTH IN
OUR PROGRAMS AND WITH OUR OFFICE
OF ENVIRONMENTAL. IN TERMS OF
REALLY MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
REALLY ROOTING OUT I THINK
EMBRACES AGAIN LIKE IN ALL ITS
FORMS I THINK I'D MENTIONED A
LETTER FROM BLACK EMPLOYEES. ALL
JUST REINFORCE THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT OTHER. RIGHT EVEN
WHAT IT FEELS LIKE INTERNAL. AND
SOME FOR BLACK EMPLOYEES RIGHT
THE ONES THAT WERE THAT LETTER.
AND OF WHAT THEY'RE DEALING WITH
RIGHT SUCH LIKE. YOU TO HAVE
THAT KIND OF. OFF OF RACIAL I.
IT DOESN'T AT BOTH THE IN. AND
THE X. AND THAT TO ME IS OUT OF
THE- ALL BUT YOU'VE ALREADY SHE
- OKAY THANK- OUR SERVER.
CONDITION THIS WHOLE THIS MATTER
OPEN. WE HOLD IT OPEN BE TALK.
WITH YOUTH YOU FOR THE- THAT'S-
CONCLUDES. NUMBER TWO- SEVEN GO
TO. ISSUE NUMBER TWO. EIGHT AND
THIS IS THAT THE- OF RE. FOR AND
RECOVERY- I IN KNOW THAT. AND WE
HAVE. DIRECTOR WAGNER GOOD
MORNING I KNOW THAT THAT. WE'RE
ONLY GOOD AT DISCUSS THE- ARE
BIODEGRADABLE PRODUCT LABELING
HIM IMPLEMENTATION EVITA. AT
TWELVE OH ONE I KNOW SENATOR
STERN WHO IS LEFT THAT DAY HAS
HAD SOME QUESTIONS ON- FIRE-
WORK THAT'S DONE AT ON SITE SAID
HE WANT TO ASK IN A DIRECT WHERE
WAGNER WHILE I HAVE YOU HERE I
JUST WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. DECIDED TO
FIRE HIM FOR STUFF THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF CONSTERNATION ABOUT THE
BOTTLE BILL THE VERY LARGE
SURPLUS IN THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER- OF FUN AS NOTED IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE A
RECENT. ARTICLE I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT- RIGHT NOW
IS NOT THE RIGHT TIME TO DO THIS
INQUIRIES SO- I'M GONNA LOOK FOR
TO AGO PRESENTED IN A LETTER TO
YOU SEE YOU KNOW THAT IT'S WORTH
COMING I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
RESPONSE. AND I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT LEAVE IT AT THAT FOR TODAY-
BUT LET'S GET INTO. PRODUCT
LABELING REQUIREMENTS AND
BIODEGRADABLE- PROGRAM YOU'RE
ASKING FOR- ONE BABIES. ONE B.
C. P. AND A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND FOR THE INTEGRATED
WASTE MANAGEMENT- PROGRAM.
THANKS SENATOR AND JUST OPEN AND%
BASS OF COURSE I AM HAPPY TO AND
TALK TO YEAR- AND SOME MEMBERS
SAID THE BUDGET COMMITTEE ABOUT-
OUR BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM- OUR WELFARE PROGRAM AND
ALL OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
CAN RECYCLE AND AS YOU WOULD
LIKE SO I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT
ISSUE TODAY HAPPY TO DO THAT IN
WRITING WHATEVER IS MOST
CONVENIENT FOR YOU OR ANSWER
QUESTIONS TODAY IF YOU HAVE
THEM. AND WE HAVE SEEN ONE AND
PROPOSAL FOR YOU TODAY I IS FOR
ONE Q. Y. DATA IMPLEMENT AB
TWELVE A WINE ADDED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM AS YOU KNOW THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT YOU ALL AND
THEY DID ON LAST YEAR IT GOES TO
THE CONFIDENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS
GOING TO FALL AND GOES HAND IN
HAND WITH OUR SENATOR ALLEN
SPELL ENTREES AND LABELING ON
WHAT IS RECYCLABLE AN INDUSTRY
WHERE IT REALLY DOES SEEM THE
WORKLOAD ON EACH SIDE OF THE
LINE. ZERO DO YOU OVERSIGHT OF
THE FEASIBILITY STUDY- THAT IS
YOUR QUESTION AB TWELVE OH ONE
ON AND ON AND ADVICE FOR
CHANGING THE WAY STRAIN BUT MORE
OVER TO DO THE RESEARCH THE
OVERSIGHT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. I'M TO YOUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND OUR OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE ARE DOING
CONTEMPLATION OF COMPOSED
ABILITY AGAIN AND AS WE DO ON
YOU KNOW. ON AND ADDRESS REALLY
REGULAR BASIS I THINK WE HAD
THIS CONVERSATION OVER THE LAST
DECADE A COUPLE OF TIMES WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THIS
INFORMATION RIGHT AND THAT WE
ARE I'M CONTINUOUSLY UPDATING
THAT INFORMATION AND
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACTS ON-
COMPOSTING WHICH AS WE ALL KNOW
IN IMPLEMENTATION OF THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE IS GOING TO BE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT THAT
WE STREAM. IS CLEAN AND THAT OUR
COMPOST OR CRYING PROVIDING TO-
PRIMARILY TO OUR AGRICULTURAL.
PARTNERS JEAN AND THE COMPANIES
THAT WE ARE YOU. AND IS FREE OF
CAN. AND SO WE THINK THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WAS I'M REALLY. AND
INCREASED THE LEAD. LEADERSHIP
AND IN PASSING THIS LET. I THAT
THE I OPPOSITION AT YOUR- FROM
RCI C. OVER THE C. C. WAS MORE A
MYSTERY. OR MISS AT. BETWEEN
ITS- AND ARE C. R. C. OVER WHAT
OUR RATE. AUTHORITY IS AND I
KNOW THAT MEMBER TEAMS FAR WITH
CLEAN UP MY- THIS YEAR. THE
CTA'S REFER. WHAT THE- SAYS- BUT
OF COURSE OUR INTENTION IS TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS AROUND
LABELING. AND TO BE VERY INTENSE
AND OF THE LEGISLATURE AND OF
THE AUTHOR I'M TO HAVE THOSE
REGULATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
LABELING. I'M NOT CREATING A NEW
BIFURCATED SYSTEM AND AS THAT IS
NOT THE AND THE INTENSE AS.
COMMUNICATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
. PUTTING ASIDE THAT THIS. OF
THAT AND- BUT JUST SEEING WHAT
WE WILL WE WHAT WE PASS SELECTED
OKAY SO WE WERE OBVIOUSLY WERE
HOLDING THIS OPEN TO DEAL WITH
THE INCONSISTENCY AND I HAVEN'T
HAD A CHANCE TO SEE IF THIS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING IS ACTUALLY
PUT A BILL ACROSS THE- ACROSS
THE DESK YET- THANK YOU FOR THAT
EXPLANATION- THE L. A. O. DO WE
HAVE A COMMENT. BOB ROSS BROWN
AGAIN WITH THE L. A. O. IS YOUR
AGENDA NOTES AND AS DIRECTOR OF
WAGNER MENTIONED WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT. IN THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT KIND OF
CLARIFYING THE INTENT OF THE
BILL AND THAT IT WOULD ONLY IS
FOR THE TRUST PRODUCT LABELING
AND NOT NECESSARILY A BIFURCATED
COLLECTION SYSTEM SO. WE'RE
USING IT MAKES SENSE TO WITHHOLD
ACTION ON THIS FOR NOW TO ALLOW
TIME TO SORT OUT. IF WE COULD
ONLY IMPROVE THE SEPARATION AND
SORTING OF ALL OUR WASTE IN OUR
RECYCLABLES AND ORGANICS AND-
IT'LL PUT OF TRUMP COULD THROW
INTO EDUCATING THE PUBLIC IN.
WHAT TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS AND
WHAT'S WHAT IS RECYCLABLE WHAT'S%
NOT RESPECTFUL BUT- THAT'S NOT
THE ISSUE BEFORE US- OKAY. IF I
COULD JUST SAY THAT REGARDLESS
OF THAT REGULATORY AND ACTION
THAT MAY BE TAKEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT THE WORKLOAD AND THEN
THEY NEED FOR THE P. Y. WILL BE
NECESSARY FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE LEGISLATION REGARDLESS OF
THE REGULATIONS. SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE THAT NOTE IS PART OF
YOUR CONCERTS. AND IT'S NOT LIKE
THERE'S A LOT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTISTS. LOOKING FOR WORK.
MAYBE THERE ARE. OKAY I DON'T
SEE ANY MEMBERS HAVING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT'S ALL I HAD I
JUST WANTED. CLARIFICATION ON
THAT- FINANCE. YOU'RE NOT ALONE
RIGHT. YES- DRIVER DEPARTMENT BY
NAY NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT RIGHT
OKAY. OKAY THAT SAYS FOR WILL
OPEN CONTAINER CONVERSE- ON ON
WHAT EXACTLY IS GONNA BE A LOT
LIKE IT WILL. OUR SO THAT'S
GOOD- I'M DONE WITH THIS ITEM
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT GO TO
THE CARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE WEATHER. THANK YOU I'M
HAPPY TO COME BACK. AND TO TALK
ABOUT WHY. AND WHEN AS SENATORS
BACK. VERY GOOD OUR LET'S MOVE
ON THE- TO ANYONE WHERE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT- SO LET
ME LOOK IN THE ROOM TH OH TWO I
SEE NO. HERE ANYBODY IT WOULD
WISHING TO COMMENT ON ANYTHING
ON TODAY'S AGENDA A REMINDER THE
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO
EIGHT THREE TO THE CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE
TEACHERS MAN CITY TITLE OF
INCENTIVES TO MONNING TODAY I'M
ASKING PEOPLE TO LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS ABOUT A MINUTE- ADULT
IF THE MONITORS THERE PLEASE
PRODDED THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY- AND WE'LL HEAR FROM
THEM. PLEASE BEGIN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
ON THIS PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ABOUT
NINE QUEUED UP AT THE MOMENT.
I'LL START WITH LINE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY GO AHEAD
FIRST. HI MY NAME'S. WILL BURY
THEM IN YOUR DIRECTOR WIENER
ADVOCACY WITH AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION- IN REGARDING- I
DON'T TWENTY FIVE WE SUPPORT
MANY ELEMENTS OF GOVERNANCE IN
THE BUDGET. OF WHAT YOU SUPPOSED
TO PUBLIC ON HELP PROTECTIVE. WE
APPRECIATE OF GOVERNMENT
APPROACH TO CRIME. IN THE
STRUGGLE TO CONTACT IN OUR ABOUT. THEN IT REALLY DOES HAVE AN
UPPER TO AGAIN MAKE IT IMPACT ON
. THEIR POLLUTION CHANGE AMERICA
. FOR THIS BUDGET. WHAT'S WRONG
IMPORTANT THE GOVERNOR'S OF THE
WALK MARC SIX POINT ONE BILLION
FOR THE AND IT FOR LOWERING. ARE
RESIDENTS AS WELL MEETING DUTY
TRUCKS. IN DOZENS OF FOR ME-
CONTRIBUTE TO CALL ARE BY. WE
ARE GOING IN A DRAINAGE TRAINS
AND WHAT THE OTHER HEAVY DUTY.
VEHICLES THE FOURTEENTH WHICH OF
EUROPE THE BALL THEIR- PROGRAM
OR PARK LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. INCLUDING
ELECTRICAL THE OTHERS ARE SOME
OF THE OPTION FOCUSED ON
REDUCING THE INCOME TROUT. THIS
IS A MULTI YEAR AND THAT WE-
TAKING A LOOK OPPORTUNE ACROSS
INVESTMENT IN THESE EQUITY PRO-
AND THE FURTHER ONE THEY WERE
SUPPORT THE NEW FOR GREATER
INVESTOR THAN ACT BASED PROGRAM
. IMPLEMENTING CLEAN UP AS
ENVISIONED BY SIX THOUSAND AND
ONGOING FOR. I DON'T ON THE OF
THE LONG TERM WE'RE GOING TO DO
TRUST FOR. PRESIDENT SB SIX. AND
FINALLY HEARD YOU CONSIDER.
EUROPE AND IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR. SMALL OPERA EQUIPMENT
TRANSITION TO ZERO- QUICKLY ALSO
THE THIS CATEGORY RECEIVED. THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN FUNDING FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL DIESEL REPLACEMENTS
AND UPGRADES. TO REALISTICALLY
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE THAT AMOUNT WE'RE ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR THE PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION FOR AIR DISTRICT
IMPLEMENTATION OF MAYBE SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY A PROTECTION
PROGRAM. HOWEVER DESPITE
ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES BEING
ADDED TO THE PROGRAM. THIS
AMOUNT IS THE SAME AS IN
PREVIOUS YEARS AND WE CONTINUE
TO NOTE. THAT AMOUNT OF
HISTORICALLY BEEN INSUFFICIENT
TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS. OF THE
STATE MANDATED PROGRAM. THE
COMMUTER PROTECTION IN SAN HAVE
BEEN REDUCED FROM TO MY AND SIX
MILLION TWO HUNDRED MEETING.
WHICH IS ANOTHER PER CUT WITH A
PROGRAM THAT ALREADY UNDER. ALL
CAPITALS. JEFF AND TWO MILLION.
A YEAR FOR TWENTY TO THREE AND
THREE TO FOUR CONTENT SEVEN
LOCAL JUST PER SCHOOL FIRE
PROGRAM. AND- I. AS WILDFIRE
EVENT BECOME MORE IN. I WOULD
IMAGINE SHE RESPOND IN THE- THAT
IS REQUIRING. MORE FROM LOCAL
INDUSTRY. DISTRICTS HAVE
NECESSARY NEEDS TO DO THE JOB.
THE NEW BUDGET. FOR A DISTRICT
MERGING RESPONSE ALLOWED TO
TRAIN AND PROVIDE. MEANS ADVICE
. THAT WOULD FOCUS ON MONITOR
INCOME. OF SMOKE I COULD DURING
THE EVENTS INCLUDING PUBLIC
OUTRAGE TO INFORM PEOPLE. CAN
AND COULD BY ON A PRO
APPROPRIATE RISK. ALSO THE
BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE FUNDING
FOR WHICH NO CLAR DIRECTION
PROGRAM- REDUCTION PROGRAM AND
WE HAD THE SENATE. EFFORT YEAR
TO PUT PHONE CAN WE HELP YOU
WITH A- AT THE YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR THE- AND THEN LAST WEEK
ENCOURAGE YOU TO READ AUTHORIZE
THE AB EIGHT INCENTIVE PROGRAM
INCLUDE THE HIGHLY. IN COLLEGE
EFFECTIVE MORE AN EIGHTY NINE
THREE NEWS PROGRAM TO OFFER.
AVOID AND HOW US MEET OUR CLEAN
AIR ACT PUBLIC. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL YOUR TIME. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS. NEXT YES GOOD
LINE THIRTY PLAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ERIKA ROMERO ON BEHALF
ON BEHALF OF VALLEY CLEAN AIR
NOW ALSO KNOWN AS VALLEY CAN
VALLEY CAN IS A FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE PUBLIC CHARITY COMMITTED
TO QUANTIFY BELIEVE REDUCING AIR
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. THE REGION WITH
THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE
UNITED STATES WE WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR SAID THE EQUITY
INVESTMENTS WHICH ALLOCATE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX MILLION
FOR CLEAN CARS FOR ALL. SEVENTY
SIX MILLION OF WHICH COMES FROM
THE CAP AND TRADE REVENUE IN THE
LAST YEAR WE'VE SEEN APPLICATION
FOR CLEAN CARS FOR ALL OF THE
TIME BACKING RALLY REACHED PEAK
LEVELS SIGNALING A GROWING
DESIRE FOR CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
TECHNOLOGY AND OUR COMMUNITY AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ENSURING THAT
FUNDING FOR THIS CRITICAL
PROGRAM IS ADEQUATELY AND
EQUITABLY PROVIDED. FOR
COMMUNITIES WHO NEED IT MOST. IN
ADDITION I'D LIKE TO MAKE
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
LECTURE VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE DELIGHTED TO
BE THE GOVERNOR'S HISTORIC
INVESTMENT AND GRAB. AND A DEBT
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS
NECESSARY TO HELP OUR STATE MEET
CLIMATE. ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT
GOALS. IN DOLLARS SENT A STRONG
MARKET SIGNAL THAT CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITTED TO REVOLUTIONIZING THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ALL TO MAKE THE FUNDING A
REALITY. THANK YOU. Q. X. NEXT
ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING SURE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS STILL A CROWD OF
SOUTH HMD THE SOUTH COAST REGION
FACES ENORMOUS CHALLENGES
REDUCING AIR POLLUTION AND TOXIC
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
ESPECIALLY IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND WE APPRECIATE
THE BABY SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM
IMPLICATIONS FUNDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR AIR
DISTRICTS HOWEVER AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED THE PROGRAM IS
SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED WE ASK THAT
YOU INCREASE FUNDING TO COVER
ACTUAL PROGRAM COSTS NEVER
COMMUNITIES IN THE PROGRAM HAS
GROWN AIR DISTRICTS ARE WORKING
AT A DEFICIT. IN THEIR EFFORTS
TO IMPLEMENT IT. RESHAPE MAYBE
SIX SEVENTEEN FOR BEING. HOWEVER
THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET HOW
REDUCED IT SO WE ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE INSTEAD INCREASE IT TOOK
PRIORITIZE MEASURED ACTIONS THAT
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SUSTAINABLE INCENTIVES IS
CRITICAL FOR MEETING HEALTH PAYS
FEDERAL AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
AND EXHILARATING SORELY NEEDED
NEAR TERMINATION REDUCTIONS WE
SUPPORT FUNDING HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY BEING
DEVELOPED FOR MASTER PLAN IN THE
FUTURE HOWEVER GIVEN OUR NEED TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH NOW. WE
SUPPORT FUNDING TO REPLACE
THOUSANDS OF HEAVY DUTY DIESEL
TRUCKS WITH NEAR ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS THAT ARE LOWER COST AND
PROVIDE MORE IMMEDIATE
REDUCTIONS THANK YOU. NEXT
EXCELLENT FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING YOUR NUMBERS
BATES WERE LARGER WITH THE CALL
CENTER AS WE ENTER INTO ANOTHER
YEAR WITH A VERY STRONG SURPLUS
WORKERS STRONG FOCUS ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND JERICHO'S AFFECTION
AREAS ARE QUITE TRANSPORTATION
NETWORKS LEGENDA CENTER G. WE
ALSO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE CALLS
FOR GREATER RESILIENCE AND
INTEGRATION. RELATED TO
SEPTEMBER STRUCTURE WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED HOWEVER THAT THERE
WAS A LACK OF INVESTMENT FOR
STRATEGIC PLANNING AND
POLITICALLY DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES LIKE SOLAR PLUS
STORAGE WHICH CAN PROVIDE
COMMUNITY AND THE RESILIENCE IN
THE FACE OF THESE OUTAGES. THAT
WE FACE INCREASING CLIMATE
DRIVEN OUTAGES RIGHT KEEP
WEIGHTS CAN MASSIVE SNOWSTORMS
THE KNOCK OUT POWER LINES THE
STRATEGIC ENERGY RESILIENCE
PLANNING METHODS AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTAL LEVEL WILL BE
CRITICAL. DO THAT AND WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION WILL BEST TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND THAT ENERGY
COMMISSION TO CREATE A GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WILL PROVIDES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOP COMMUNITY
AND YOUR RESPONSE PLANS
LEVERAGING CLEAN DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES STOCK AGAINST
LEPROSY. PROGRAMS OUT IN
SATURDAY SB EIGHT THIRTY THREE
WHICH WERE INTRODUCED EARLIER
THE YEAR ADDITIONAL WE ARE STILL
IN THE TRAY TO OUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR A GENERAL FUND
FOR THE AMPLE OF THIS COMMUNITY
AND PLANS MODEL ON THE ENERGY
COMMISSION ENERGY PROGRAM.
PERSONAL DRY DOWN BUT GREENHOUSE
EMISSION AS WELL AS TALK
AIRCRAFT MISSION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. YOU MIX. ONE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CARE JULIE NOW ENOUGH BOTTLE
THEY HAVE THE K. ELECTRIC TRAINS
COALITION SPEAKING TO ASIAN
TWENTY IN THE CAP AND-
EXPENDITURES. FIRST IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO THE GOVERNOR AND THE-
FOR IT CONTINUED TO ZERO MAY B.
AS AND THE SUPPORTING IN. YOU
LEAD THE NAY WITH THE COMMITMENT
OF PUBLIC DAHLE TO MISSION
TRANSFER FUTURE MADE BY ANY.
WE'RE THRILLED FIFTEEN BUDGET
PROPOSED RECOGNIZED THE AND CHIU
THAT LIE AT TO MEET OUR TRANSFER
CLINICAL BY MAKING ADDITIONAL
MULTI YEAR COMMITMENTS IN THE
AREA WE FULLY SUPPORT THESE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT WITH A G.
MODIFICATIONS AT THAT TIME. SURE
WE GET OUT HERE SHE HAS NO AND
FIVE FOR THE CYCLE. FIVE HUNDRED
TO MILLION ALEX TO BE R. P.
WHICH IS INCLUDED IN THE PACKAGE
EQUITY PROVISION. OVER THREE DID
NOT RE ANY. AND MEDIAN AMOUNT AT
TO FULLY. THE RP IS CLOSER TO
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
WE IN ADDITION HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR CTRP.
AND WOOD ADDITIONALLY REQUEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDE
DIRECTION THE CARD TO READ THAT
THAT THE NEW RESTRICTIONS THAT
IT'S IMPOSED ON THE PROGRAM.
WHICH IS SENDING THE WRONG
MESSAGE TO NEW CAR BUYERS WHICH
LOOK TO THESE INCENTIVES AND THE
DECISION TO CHOOSE A NEW
ELECTRIC CAR OVER A GASOLINE CAR
. SECOND WE THE COURT INCLUDING
A HUNDRED MILLION FOR ADDITIONAL
ZERO EMISSION PILOT. THE
DIFFICULTY AND TRANSPORTATION
FREIGHT CORRIDORS LIKE THE I
SEVEN TEN FREEWAY. THANK YOU FOR
THE ARE TO SPEAK AND WILL PUT
ALL IN RIGHT TO YOU IN THE CAN
AND THE SHORT FUTURE. THANK YOU
ZACKS. FIND EIGHT PLEASE GO.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M ALLEN ABS
WITH THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT- SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF COMMON PREVIOUSLY
MADE BATES MADE BY MY COMMENT-
COUNTERPARTS IN CAPCO AND
SOUTHCOAST REGARDING- REVERSING
CUTS TO THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
PROGRAM THE FARMER PROGRAM AND A
DESIRE TO RE OPERATE THE ABA
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION- WE HAVE
SUPPORT FOR THE THAT LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS BUT I'D
LIKE TO ADD- TWO ITEMS FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER ONE WOULD
BE TO CONTINUE AND INTEMPERANCE
FOR THE SMALL OFF ROAD-
EQUIPMENT ENGINES INCLUDING
COMMERCIAL LAWN AND GARDEN
EQUIPMENT LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET SO FAR
DOESN'T HAVE ANY MONEY ALLOCATED
TO THAT PROGRAM WHICH HELPS. NOT
ONLY URBAN OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT
OPERATORS BUT ALSO RURAL OFF
GRID EQUIPMENT OPERATORS AND
ALSO SUGGEST THE LEGISLATURE
LOOK AT SUPPORTING COMBAT
AIRCRAFT THROUGH A NEW INCENTIVE
PROGRAM COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT
IS YOU KNOW A WILL BE SUBJECT TO
A NEW CARD REGULATION TO BE
APPROVED THIS YEAR AND SO
STARTING AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM
NOW TO- ENCOURAGE EARLY ADOPTION
NOT ONLY HELPS KEEP THESE
BUSINESSES VIABLE BUT ALSO.
HELPS THE MEET CLEAN AIR
STANDARDS. FOR THE FUTURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. SIX
WHY TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER ONE MOUNT VERNON CHÁVEZ
BECAUSE BEGAN WASTE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE THE COOLEY INQUIRE OF ON
FROM FOR COLLEGE BECAUSE THEY
THREE PROGRAM UNDER THE CAPTAIN
TRADE WHILE YOU'RE AWAYOF UNDER
MORE ALSO NOTHING MENTION BY
THEIR OKAY WASTE FROM LANDFILLS
. MAJORITY GIVES A CAR BY INTO
EFFECT ON THE GROWTH YEAR AND
BEFORE THE CAPTAIN TRADE ON ARE
AMONG ONLY FOR THE FUNDING FOR
THE IMPORTANT PROGRAM A PROGRAM
MANAGER TALENT OF TO BE
INCREDIBLE SUCCESSFUL NUMBER
ABOUT EFFECTIVE METHOD IN TERMS
DOLLARS. FOR GREENHOUSE GAS. BOB
HERTZBERG SIGNIFICANT AND THAT
AND FIVE COOPER. AND AGAIN
BEVERAGES GOT BATES. NECKS LINE
TWENTY THREE CALL. ACCORDING TO
REMEMBER AND CHANGE INCOME COME
OF THE SENATE HOUSE- ARE GOING
TO FINANCES BY MANY OF THE
CLIMATE AIR QUALITY INVESTMENTS
IN THEIR THE- AND THEIR MOM. I
DIDN'T MUCH NOT EQUITY IN ON
JUST START ALL PROGRAMS
INCLUDING BUILDING ON PREVIOUS
FUNDING CRIME RESILIENCE CENTERS
AND OTHER COULD SUPPORT FOR
CLEANING SPACE IN THE FRONT
CLIMATE. WE TO HELP THEM ALSO AS
CONTINUES A COULD USE YOUR
PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY VISION OF
THING WATER ENTRANCE FROM I
THINK. PROGRAM THAT WE CONTINUE
TO JEFF YEAR THE STATE
INVESTMENT OF TAXPAYER REPAIRED
IN THE SCALE FARM DAIRY.
ASSOCIATES FOR FALL OF FACT
FARMED OUT THE DAY DIGESTER WE
AGREED THERE IS NOTHING IN THE
ISSUE THAT WE MUST ADDRESS THE
REALITY THAT THERE DAYS AFTER
THE MASSACRE COST IN THEM RENDON
DECIDED THE NEXT OF THE DAIRIES
EXACERBATING A AND WATER AND
RURAL LOW INCOME OF COLOR IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
SOLIDIFYING STATE'S RELIANCE ON
NATURAL GAS AND IT FINALLY
TRANSITION TO ELECTRIFICATION
CREDIBLE. WE ALSO ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
TECH COMMUNITIES FROM EXPOSURE
OF THE STATE WORKS TO TRANSITION
AWAY FROM HARMFUL AND TOXIC
PESTICIDES AND COMMITTED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
SUPPORT SON AND TO CONTINUE TO
AND WORK TOWARDS THE MULTIPLE
AVENUES TO ADDRESS BESIDES A
PROPHECY IS BETTER- ONGOING. IT
ALSO HAS A OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
IT COMMITMENT TO THE REGION
AROUND THE AND IMPACT BY THE
RISK. FROM THE BY INVESTING
SUCCESS IN PRADA THAT THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF. MEMBERS SUCH
AS CLIMATE RESILIENT MULTI BEEN
. INTEREST INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
THAT REGION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT. NEXT WE HAVE LINE TO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBERS DECLINED JOB ON
BEHALF OF CAL START TO GIVE A
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE TWENTY FIVE
RELATING TO THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN WE APPLAUD
GOVERNOR NUISANCE PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR PUTTING THE
APPROPRIATE FOCUS ON CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION I FACT WHEN
EMISSIONS IN THE MOST POLLUTING
SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA WILL PAVE
THE WAY. FOR ME IN THE STATE
THEN BISHOP CLIMATE GOALS
REDUCING AIR POLLUTION CREATING
JOBS AND MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES
HEALTHIER AND MORE EQUITABLE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT
ZERO MISSION MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES AS ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THESE
VEHICLES WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT A PORTION OF THE-
FUNDING BE USED SPECIFICALLY FOR
PUBLIC TRUST CHARGING.
ADDITIONALLY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK EQUITY
INVESTMENTS WHICH ALLOCATES TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX MILLION
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CLEAN
CARTS FOR ALL PROGRAMS AND OTHER
EQUITY PROGRAMS WE APPLAUD THE
EFFORTS TO BRING CLEAN VEHICLES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
THAT THE COMMUNITY THAT NEED
THEM THE MOST. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO ENSURE THAT FUNDING. IS
DISTRIBUTED RIGHT. THANKS NEXT
WE HAVE LONG THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING I'M JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA WE
REGRETFULLY HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT THAT'S POWER CYCLES
AB TELVE A ONE IMPLEMENTATION
AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR WE DON'T
DISPUTE THE OVER ARCHING REQUEST
OR THE NEED FOR ONE P. Y. IN A
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THAT NEED WILL EXIST
REGARDLESS BUT WE DO OBJECT TO
THE SCOPE OF THE WORK OUTLINED
IN THE B. C. P. AS EXPRESS WE
BELIEVE IT DEPARTS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT IN PASSING
THE BILL- WE THINK THAT THE BC
CONTEMPLATES- THE POWER CYCLES
REGULATIONS WOULD REQUIRE-
BIFURCATION OF THE COLLECTION
SYSTEM RATHER THAN PRODUCT
LABELING WHICH IS WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED. WHY THIS
IS IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF POTENTIAL COSTS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LOGISTICAL
CHALLENGES AT A TIME WHEN WE'RE
ALREADY TRYING TO IMPLEMENT THE
NEW ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING
REGULATIONS WE DO APPRECIATE THE
THOROUGH DISCUSSION OF THE ISSUE
ON THE ANALYSIS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIANG AND POWER
CYCLE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE. BUT
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR ISSUE TWENTY ONE
POWER CYCLED MATERIALS
MANAGEMENT LOCAL SYSTEM
PERMITTING STAFF ON THE BOAT
ONLY COUNTER THAT'LL BE UP NEXT
WEEK AND ALSO SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S SOLID
INORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING GOALS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANKS WE HAVE ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS CAPTAIN
CAME IN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES. HAD THE
PLAN TO ITEM TODAY FIRST WE WANT
TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDING FOR STATE
MANDATES RELATED TO ORGANISED
WEEK ORGANIC INTRODUCTION TO BE
ALLOCATED FOR THOSE WHO ARE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT THE USUAL.
IF THE GOAL IS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS MUCH IT
IS THANK CAP AND TRADE FUNDS
SHOULD BE USED WITH THE COURT
THIS PROGRAM EXTENSIVELY WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND TO
CONTINUE OUR WORK HERE AND THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN BREAK TEARS
ON THAT PROGRAM. SECOND I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK COMMITTEE FACTOR
THEIR THROWN OUT THAT THE ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT IMPLEMENTATION OF
AB TWELVE OR ONE THE COMPOSTABLE
AND BIODEGRADABLE PRODUCT
LABELING IMPLEMENTATION- WE
ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS WITH OUR
COLLEGE. HERE AND THE INTENT WAS
TO ADDRESS PRODUCT LABELING ON
OF REGULATIONS AND THAT FURTHER
BIFURCATE THE WAY COLLECTION
SYSTEM HE GREATEST ISSUE MY
RESULTS DURING THE BY DELIVER
AND APPRECIATE COMMENTS DIRECTOR
WAGNER EARLIER IN THE YEAR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR TIME.
YOU NECK. YES WE HAVE LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING CENTER MY NAME IS KRISH
SPEAKING ON TWENTY FIVE BE ON
BECAUSE OF BOTH FOR CLEAN AIR
THAT'S WHAT THE CHARGE HEAD CAL
CAMPAIGN WE APPLAUD GOVERNING
NUISANCE TO EQUITY CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO MEET ITS CLIMATE
COMMITMENTS AND AIR QUALITY
OBLIGATIONS HINGES ON MAKING
SURE ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION.
WE ALSO SUPPORT CARD GOING ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS FOCUSING
MANY OF THEIR PROGRAMS A
DISADVANTAGE IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WE WOULD OPPOSE ANY
ROLLBACKS THOSE PROTECTIONS AND
- THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS.
CALIFORNIA MUST INVEST IN STATE
EQUITY PROGRAMS INCLUDING CLEAN
CARTS FOR ALL STABLE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECT
AND OTHER CLEAN MOBILITY
PROJECTS THESE ELECTIONS ARE
AMONG THE MOST TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE TOOL BETTER DISPOSAL AT
THE SIR COMMUNITIES THAT NEED
THE TRANS CLEAN. IN THE MOST WE
ALSO URGE LEGISLATION TO BEGIN
CONSIDERING THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUTURE BEYOND THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT
RECEIVE YOUR P. RATHER WE
CHALLENGE THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT
DISADVANTAGED LOW INCOME AND
HARD TO REACH ME AT THE CENTER
OF CALIFORNIA'S. TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION STRATEGY. WE
ALSO SUPPORT- AND THAT'S TO GOD
CLEAN MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
FIEGER. AS DIESEL ENGINES ARE AN
OUTSIDE COULD TO OUR CHALLENGES
WELL AS CREATE CAR. DIESEL
MATTER. LASTLY WE WITH THE
CONCERT AND NEEDS TO INCREASE-
CHARGING IN FILLING
INFRASTRUCTURE- I'D LIKE ALSO ON
BEHALF JUST CCA SUPPORT WILL
BERWICK'S COMMENTS EARLIER AND
ALSO SUPPORT INCREASE FUNDING.
FOR EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THE EX. NEXT
LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ALCHEMY GRAHAM AND
I'M A LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT
EIGHTY FIVE TRANSIT AND RAIL
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND WE HAVE A TOTAL OF TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MEMBERS WHICH
INCLUDES EMISSION BEST
MANUFACTURING. I'M CALLING
INTRODUCED TO THE ASSOCIATION
REPORT FOR THE CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES WHICH WERE
DISCUSSED IN ITEM THIRTY NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE SIXTY.
OBSTACLE THE TO THE TO CLEANER
VEHICLE IN THE COST TO BE. AS AS
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THE
MULTI YEAR INVESTMENTS WILL TO
HELP AGENCIES. MORE
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND HELP REACH
THEIR GOALS BY TWENTY FORTY
THANK YOU. THANKS YES WE HAVE
LINE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING HERE NUMBERS
NICOLE KOREAN WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE I'M COMMENTING IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
TWELVE ALL ONE WHICH WAS
SUPPORTED BY CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE INTO COMPOST
ABILITY STANDARDS FOR PRODUCTS
LABELED OUT COMPOSTABLE. AB
TROUBLE ONE AND CAN TO SET
CONTENT AND LABELING
REQUIREMENTS FOR COMPOSTABLE
PRODUCTS TO REDUCE GREENWASHING
AND DETECTIVES CLAIM. IDENTIFIED
IN THE ANALYSIS SOME HAVE ARGUED
THAT THE BILL CURRENTLY WHICH
CAN BE CONSTRUED AS GRANTING
POWER CYCLE ABILITY TO ADOPT NEW
pGOVERNMENTS TO COLLECT
COMPOSTABLE PLASTICS SEPARATELY
FROM OTHER ORGANIC WASTES. BOTH
THE AUTHOR AND SUPPORTERS HAVE
CLARIFIED THAT THE INTENT WAS
ONLY TO ALLOW SEPARATELY WE
REQUIREMENTS IF I COULD GET A
COLLECTION A- AND I KNOW YOU
WOULD ALREADY WITH. TO PLACE AN
MANDATE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THEREFORE WE WITH THE COURT THE
ADDITION OF THIS. LANGUAGE IN
THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL. AND
HEALTH CARE RECYCLED ABILITY TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT AB TWELVE OH ONE
IT'S CRUCIAL TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS FROM DECEPTIVE
ADVERTISING. WE URGE YOU TO
ADOPT THIS ITEM THAT THIS CHANGE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
. X. EXCEPT ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER NUMBERS DOESN'T
MATTER NOT I'M CALLING THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE CONSCIOUS AND
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE-
ADDITION IT'S GENERALLY SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S INVESTMENT IN
THE CARPENTRY- PROGRAMMED BY-
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED MORE MONEY
IN CANNOT RELY SO HEAVILY ON THE
BUDGET YOUR CLASS. IN ADDITION
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE AND I LIKE
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS- ON THE FUNDING FOR
DADS- BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS IN SOME
OF THAT LOW INCOME PROGRAMS LIKE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL. AND BEHIND
EACH YEAR- NUMBER ON ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN- BUT WE'RE
GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CALL- AS MENTIONED BY. THE CARD
. PRESENTED ON TO THE CREATURE
SHOCKLEY PROGRAM BY. FEEL THAT
THEIR- CONTINUES TO BE A LACK OF
COORDINATION AMONGST VERY EACH.
THAT WOULD PREFER TO A WHOLE OF
EITHER. IN CENTER. THESEVENTY-
AND SO. A COMMENT BETTER CHAIR
MANY OTHER MEMBERS. THE
COMMITTEE- WITCHER TO THANK YOU
MUCH. Q. NEXT. NEXT WE HAVE A
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO. GOOD
MORNING NUMBER FORTY DOLLARS
BEHALF OF SALT LAKE CITY NOT
AMERICA ITS TOWARD CAL CHAPTER.
THE ECHO OF THE COMMON MADE BY
HERE SEEM EXACTLY SHE EIGHT I'LL
ALWAYS OBJECT TO THE FUNDING
NEED FOR THE WEBER FEET TALL ONE
COMMITTEE BEGIN. OF THAT OUTLINE
THE BCP OF THE GLOBAL WAR
COMPLEMENT IN THE T. P. A
COMPLEX WITH THE ONE INTENT OF
DOT EIGHT. ALTHOUGH ONE WILL FOR
IT CAL CYCLE THE NUMBER AND
BUNCH CAN ON. COURTEN NOTHING
REDUCTION EFFORTS AND WE'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
PROPOSING AN ADDITIONAL FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS. AND
NOTHING REDUCTION FUNDING FOR
THIS YEAR HOWEVER WE APPRECIATE
AND AGREE WITH THE COMMENT BY
CHAIR LIKE HOW INTERNET ARM OF
WIRE THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE
IN THIS AREA. PARTICULARLY WHEN
THEY GARY MAPPING REDUCTION
PROGRAMS HAVE CONSISTENTLY BEEN
AMONG THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
CLIMATE PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANKS MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ARE ACCEPTABLE CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS IS A MENTION PREVIOUS. THE
VOTE ON CAL WILL BE RESCHEDULED
TO FEBRUARY NINTH SO WE CAN-
ADDRESS THAT. I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY FROM THE-
ADMINISTRATION AND THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE- IF SOMEBODY WAS UNABLE
TO- TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENT OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO CLEAN YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD.
THANK YOU ALL WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION- COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU WERE FEDERAL AND- THE NEXT
BUDGET SEASON THIS WILL CONCLUDE
TODAY'S HEARING WILL MEET NEXT
WEDNESDAY AT NINE O'CLOCK WE ARE
CHURNED.